I saw it in a dream.
Half-Life 3.
Hello, everybody.
Welcome.
We got 12 minutes until...
Summer Game Pass.
Yeah?
Oh my gosh, somebody watch-alongs this week.
Can I get a moi moi, happy birthday, babe?
Bitch!
Moi moi, moi, happy birthday, babe!
Happy birthday!
Don't get my hopes up.
Miss Peggy 3.
Sorry, I just dropped something.
No.
Okay, wait.
Did that?
Oh my gosh.
I have tea.
Like a hot...
giant hot cup of tea right or hot coffee oh my gosh I think
I just picked it up and it's on like a coaster and I think
it just burned my coaster that's never happened before but
no it's a my peek-a-me coaster but it's you hear that it's
like a there's like a little small match maybe not i don't
know anyway i just won't use it right now you hear something
my tea might be too hot maybe the tea is piping hot baby
because summer game fest is here let me make sure i don't
have a cat in my room i have when i have one of my cats in
my room, they inevitably yell at me to leave my room.
Wait, it started.
Huh?
It started on some other streams.
This is literally the Game Awards YouTube channel.
How is that possible?
I'm on the Game Awards YouTube channel.
It says it starts at 5 p.m.
A person came from 10 minutes in the future.
There's a pre-show?
Oh.
Yeah, I don't think it started, you guys.
The timer...
Here, I'll even do two-time zoom for you.
I'll play back.
Actually, I've had this on for a while, though, so it's
probably actually...
Oh.
See?
Oh, yeah, we're fine.
There we go.
Clearly they got the time zone wrong.
Yeah, they decided to start nine minutes early.
Yeah, top of the hour is so old school.
We're new.
We're avant-garde.
Time is a social construct anyway.
Oh, Nimmy trolled her audience by using footage from last
year.
Well, I'm...
You guys, as much as I love Nimmy, this is my watch log.
So try to follow the rules about, you know, mentioning other
streamers and such.
You know.
Thank you, though.
Yeah.
Brittany, thank you so much for the fift and genta.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm.
Well, yeah.
Congrats on the concert announcement.
Yeah!
Concert!
Anime!
NYC weekend!
So, super duper excited.
We can talk more about it later.
Well, I guess...
I don't know, actually, what is there to talk about?
It's...
Oh.
Well, no, we have eight minutes.
It is...
It's me?
Nimi!
We'll be in 3D.
And then Keiki Hime and Phoebe.
will be in...
3D!
They're real people!
And...
There may be some special guests as well.
So...
And then...
Yeah, 3D and 3D...
4D!
You could probably smell them.
That's the 4D aspect.
Wait, are we 4D?
What?
What dimension are we in, actually?
What dimension is this?
The fifth dimension.
You are 2.5D.
2.5?
No, I could be 3D.
Wait, how am I 8.5?
Yeah.
But it'll be lots of fun.
Um, I'm...
I'm scared.
I'm nervous.
It...
Was definitely something that was put together.
But, um...
Yeah!
You know, yeah, it's in New York, so it's the East Coast.
For all those who lament about every...
event being in California.
Rejoice, for we have hit the other coast.
I'm gonna eat my potato.
Oh, I am.
East Coast loves me so much, they keep welcoming me back.
Potato time.
Length, width, and height are the three dimensions.
Four is usually considered time.
Then what's a 4D movie?
4D movie is smell-o-vision.
So...
Hmm.
I think then every movie, if it's time, every movie would be
4D.
We hit the other coast.
The east coast, baby.
All of them, but only aware of third, also moving the fourth
and fourth.
mentioned but without any way of controlling that movement
so we are products we have no free will is that what you're
telling me you're telling me that we have no free will we
don't know how to control ourselves yeah it's
really funny when people like use their free will like you
could just do anything.
Have you ever thought about that?
What's stopping you from doing, from just, from setting up a
tea party in the middle of the street?
What's stopping you?
Laws.
Yeah, but I don't think there's anything lawful about that.
A tea party in the middle of the street?
Obstructing traffic, maybe.
You can execute your free will.
What do you mean?
The streets belong to the people.
My potato.
Actually, I have chicken nuggets too.
I didn't get to eat before stream, sorry.
Oh, is this guy here?
Hi, Dasko!
Hello, my wife.
Hello.
Potato and nuggies.
Oh, yeah.
Perfect way to celebrate graduating with a bachelor's!
Congratulations!
Congrats!
Are you going to visit Federal Hall while in the Big Apple?
Of course.
But it's still under construction, I think.
Give me some nuggies.
Mine.
They're all mine.
I'm so hungry.
Okay, I'll give you a bite.
We got three minutes left!
Yeah, banana is some yogurt and an apple.
Okay, Mr. Healthy over there.
I had a banana for breakfast, though!
Still in our construction since last April.
I'm hoping...
For, yes, Final Fantasy VII Remake, part three.
I'm hoping for Half-Life 3.
I'm hoping for threes.
Everything...
All the good is a 3.
New Devil May Cry 3.
Kingdom Hearts 3 plus.
Just 3.
I'm looking forward to the game 3.
Yeah, MGS 3 again.
No control of the fourth dimensional movement.
Just means you can only go forward in time.
So maybe or maybe not free will.
That's pretty deep.
We can't even control...
Time.
What's the point?
Alright, go.
Thank you so much for the fun.
Good time.
Baldur's Gate 3 squared.
Everything will be 3.
Red Dead Redemption 3.
It's gonna happen.
I hope we get another announcement of a video game movie.
Hayden, thank you so much for the fun.
I hope they make a movie of Wait, did you see that the guy,
what's his name, Kane Pearson's?
Oh my gosh, wait, what did they actually show the Bloodborne
movie trailer?
Wouldn't that be kind of insane?
Did you see that, what's his, Kane Pearson's, the director
of the back room, said that he wants to make a portal movie?
I think I'm kind of down for it.
Honestly, I feel like Half-Life movie would go insane too.
Oh, sorry, I just noticed that this is like, oh, there we
go.
One more minute!
I'm gonna pee myself!
Video games!
Water and taco!
Thank you so much for the tag!
Get the...
Sorry, I had coffee.
So I'm...
I'm...
Ah!
Down.
I can't!
Video games!
I'm a gamer, I'm a gamer, I'm a gamer.
Peter mentioned 13 minutes.
She's caffeinated.
That's a 4-4-1!
Thank you!
E2M.
It's starting!
Jeff Keeley, can you see me?
Please, welcome to the stage, the creator of the Game
Awards, Jeff Keeley!
Ah!
He said my name!
Woohoohoo!
Nice suit, Mr. Keeley.
Yes, you guys are prepped and ready.
Wait, Devil May Cry.
That's literally Dante's outfit.
Don't worry.
All right.
Hello, everybody, and welcome to Summer Game Fest.
Gaming's biggest global showcase of what's next.
You know, we started SGF back in 2020 because we didn't want
to lose that magic moment every June when gamers around the
world come together to hype ourselves about the future.
New worlds, new stories, new characters.
buttons are crazy.
Yeah, maybe the return of some fan favorites too.
This is our seventh and biggest SGF and I have to say guys,
the magic is back.
We have a great show for you today.
You prompt.
Why is jigsaw in the front row?
Now over the next two hours, we alongside some of the
world's most talented game developers are going to show you
why gaming's best days are right for us.
What I love about SGF is that we put plot.
forms and rivalries aside it doesn't matter where you play
everyone is welcome here right now everyone has a lot of
games you can see behind me in just the first five months of
2026 steam saw a record setting 9 265 new game releases and
that's up from 7 800 last year there are now more games and
more creators than at any point in the history of this great
I'm gonna act that I'm gonna become I'm gonna act that
numbers and think I'm gonna become a game developer Anyone
possibly break through with their game, but then You look
closer so far this theme ten of those they come from anyone
possibly break What does that mean?
But then you look closer stream is haunted Wait, why did it
send us back?
We can control it the fourth dimension you guys they come
from independent publishers.
Isn't that great?
absolutely and most of them were brand new IPs like that
what is happening what's happening my stream players you
guys are hungry for new experiences I'm hungry in general
actually originality games at different price points and
when developers take bold creative swings turns out you guys
show up for them really great so congratulations to all
those games thank you thank you thank you really some games
they become global blockbusters but others actually find
smaller passionate communities that love them deeply and
today both of those kinds of success matter the truth is not
every game has to be for everyone that That's what makes
this medium so exciting right now and makes SGF so
rewarding.
Because this show helps drive discovery.
I hope you find your next favorite game today.
Delayed, are we?
Oh, here we go.
So get ready.
I'm ready.
To get wishlisting, should we get on with the show?
Yes, sir!
Yeah!
Not a single person on their phone.
It's beautiful.
It's gonna be a fun ride.
So let's get started with our preview of what's ahead.
Woo!
With our first announcement.
What, what, what?
Kingdom Hearts.
I don't know.
Bloodborne.
What if they skip Bloodborne 2?
They go to Bloodborne 3.
Half-life.
I'm so sorry.
I don't know why my stream is actually...
Oh, I didn't... There were names there.
I didn't get to read them, though.
Great, Carson.
We?
Yes.
Oh, she's fine.
Oh no!
So, you're the American who called earlier, the sister of
the men on the third floor.
Ah, welcome to Paris.
It's so nice to meet you.
This looks like Resident Evil, maybe like a DLC or
something.
It's freezing.
Come in.
We don't want you to catch a cold.
Catch a cold.
I hate to say it, but...
Men's face reveal!
Oh, you are...
When I get my hands on you.
Who knows?
Maybe this is what I would look like if I was still alive.
Oh, Grandma.
What?
My stream is buffering!
Oh, sorry.
I'm so sorry, you guys.
Let me refresh for real.
Why am I so far behind?
In we go.
Guys, I don't know what's going on, actually.
I feel like I'm watching a YouTube poop.
In we go.
Open's door.
Closes door.
In we go.
I think I just cleaned it up a week ago.
It's like a boulder hole through here.
Huh?
Ah, the delightful biscuit.
Oh, I'm sure he's speaking, but there's no words coming out.
Wait, it's the...
audio?
I'll bring some nice coffee to go with a biscuit.
Summer games and YouTube poop.
I'm just kind of... Did the cigarettes?
The cigarettes didn't say Virgil on them.
Did I... Wait.
Virgil.
Yes?
Best summer games best ever.
I'm not even gonna try to fix it.
Guys, I can't be bothered to keep attempting.
Is this a spooky?
I mean, this is a spooky game, but, like, I don't want to
get jump-scared in the trailer.
Visage 2?
Ah!
Oh, my God.
I got jump-scared in the trailer!
V has come, too.
R-E, yeah.
R-E.
Where's that evil?
Don't move.
Claire Redfield.
Veronica!
Oh!
Oh my god!
My man, so happy.
Too many zombies.
Three out of ten.
2027!
blood rain Capcom on a roll what a way to kick off the show
Resident Evil Veronica revisits yeah must be the new suits
opens to our positive before closing door here we go closes
the door someone please or we make this into a YouTube poop
for real whatever we just experienced I'm glad we
experienced it together in the world
wait is this a different game sorry I wasn't listening to oh
no Muppets hello there I'm Cuphead here at Studio MDHR
headquarters.
And today, we have a special announcement for all of you.
More Cuphead?
We're happy to confirm that development has begun on a brand
new and animated Cuphead video game.
Whoa!
Our talented team is hard at work on this ambitious project,
which will take Cuphead and friends on a fresh, exciting
adventure.
Oh!
Hmm.
It's still in early stages, but we look forward to revealing
more when the time is right.
well from all of us here at studio mdhr thank you for i knew
it was gonna ring i didn't know this was plugged in hello
yes oh indeed brown what am i eating a big potato yes i'll
tell them yes if you had to experience that and try to tell
your friend about it later it seems i have one more A small
team within our studio has been working in secret on
something completely different.
This new project is a love letter to the era that brought us
into the world of video games.
We have prepared a sneak peek and I'd say...
I was gonna say, what does that mean?
It's like...
It's pretty radical.
It's Pong.
It's just like...
Pretty radical.
Tetris?
Yeah, Pong too.
Yeah, exactly.
I'm glad you guys thought the same thing.
Now in development at Studio MDHR.
Oh, it's so cute.
It's Mighty Cuphead Adventure.
A new fast action platform shooter with arcade quality
graphics and amazing sound.
Mighty Cuphead Adventure.
He has a little guy following him that looks awfully
familiar.
Mega Man Cuphead.
That's cute though.
You know, I love my puppy.
That was great.
And there you have it.
Two brand new games from Studio MDHR up in Canada with
Mighty Cuphead Adventure, a true 8-bit action platformer
coming to consoles and PC, and then a brand new
hand-animated Cuphead game has been confirmed too.
Great news.
All right.
Well, now please join me in welcoming my co-host and partner
in a new game discovery website called Looking for Game.
It's Lucy James, everyone.
Looking for Game.
Hello, Lucy.
Goodbye, Jeff.
Thanks, Jeff.
Oh, my gosh, I love her dress.
It's so cute.
I'm excited to share in so many incredible announcements.
Cute dress.
Yeah, right.
It's a game we've all been waiting to see for a long time.
The lady on stage.
Oh.
Something we've been excited to see for a long time.
Life 3.
Saw the game.
Bloodborne 2.
Sega!
Sega.
Sega in 20th century.
It gives like alien vibes.
Oh my gosh, alien isolation three.
Huh?
Yes.
Please show her.
Yeah.
Yeah, baby!
Oh!
Oh, yes!
Inomorf!
Yay!
Oh, I've really got to play the first one.
I'm so scared, though.
Ah!
I'm really glad that people came around to Alien Isolation.
I know that some people...
Hi, I'm Alhob, Creative Director of Alien Isolation 2.
When it first came out, they were like, Oh, nothing
happened.
That's so boring.
M-M-M-Mow.
But I'm so glad.
Maybe if I play as like a collab with somebody else.
We're very excited to share our return to the survival
horror genre.
It's been 12 years since we released the first survival
horror games.
We're horror games.
Crazy.
Creating an authentic new chapter, which builds on that core
isolation experience of escaping the terrifying, unkillable,
relentless alien.
And this time we're unleashing the alien on an unsuspecting
colony world from the claustrophobic confines of the colony.
I was thinking of either Phoebe or Ricky to be my.
My backseat driver.
For the ultimate apex predator.
Players will face a desperate struggle to survive and
escape, and we cannot wait to show you more in the future.
Whoa, our hair is crazy.
Wow, that must be so hard to maintain.
I would know.
I have white hair too.
Thanks so much, Anna and Al.
Today we are honored to have one of Gaming's true
visionaries here with us in the audience.
For more than two decades, his work has reminded us that
games can be emotional and deeply human.
From Eco to Shadow of the Colossus to the Last Guardian, he
has left an unforgettable mark on this media.
Please join me in recognizing the legendary Tamito Ueda-san.
Ueda-san, great to see you.
And now, let's talk about his next game.
A few years ago, we gave you an early glimpse at Ueda-san's
next game, known as Project Robot.
Oh, I love Robot.
It's time to step deeper into the mysterious, unsettling,
and epic world that marks Ueda's first game in a decade.
Let's take a look.
Oh.
Project Robot.
Could be huge.
If about Robot.
Whoa!
That looks like insane though.
Actually, like the the the the sand looked so fine
And relax it's sand I like sand actually, you know, I hate
sand.
It's coarse and something and gets everywhere
No, I don't mean like dang that sand is fine.
I mean like it didn't look It looks soft Speaking of Robots'
cave banner soon.
I know!
They were not kidding.
Project Robot is real.
Oh, no!
Skim is just all visuals.
It's so beautiful.
Oh, yeah!
Punching robots!
Gen Atlas.
this gives pound sand a different meaning what does that
mean incredible oh all right i cannot wait for gen atlas
thank you oh wait a son all right well next one of my
favorite things about these about like these game show
things is they don't kind of they show a thing and don't
really allow you to marinate in it they're just like wow
wasn't that great anyway the next game that we had it always
makes me fighting against impossible it always makes me
laugh of robots game they move so quickly i know i get it
they have a lot to show usually but it's just always like oh
that was incredible anyway the next game we have it gets me
every time
it's like a perpetual wrap it up sign is is as soon as the
segments start they're like wrap it up Onto the next.
Hmm.
Warriors.
I probably have the entire wrong dynasty.
Do not pursue Lulipur.
My first Supertime has just said, Thank you for the
Supertime!
Drink lots of water!
Whoa!
They're sticking their sticks through the door.
Uh-oh.
You good?
You got all of them?
Looks like it.
Nobody left!
Hope, just kidding!
Dang.
That's like in Minecraft when the render distance is too
low.
And then you turn it off and you see the rest of them.
Mm-hmm.
Blood message.
Cool.
Now, please welcome a game developer who is visiting the U
.S.
for the first time in two decades.
Whoa!
From RGG Studio, it's Masayoshi Yokoyama.
I know some people were wanting more information about this,
so...
Hello everyone, this is Yokoyama.
Today, we have an exciting new update about Stranger Than
Heaven.
Let's take a look at this.
The tattoos go so crazy.
They're just, they look like they're wearing onesies.
They're so awesome.
It takes place entirely in the bathhouse.
Snoop Dogg!
Akio Otsuka!
Oh!
Who does he voice?
Akio Otsuka is the voice actor for Snake in Japanese.
Oh!
We have a release date.
What if this was like the way that they told everybody that
he didn't die?
Stranger than heaven, but we released on January 15th, 2027.
Tupac has been alive this whole time.
As you may have noticed in the trailer, we revealed some
interesting new cast members.
To tell you more about that, I'd like to bring out a special
guest.
2 o'clock.
Snoop Dogg.
Oh, Snoop Dogg.
My breath.
It's good.
This is so strange.
Everyone's talking about this game.
Snoop Dogg is so tall.
Holy cow.
He's towering over everybody.
Tell us, how does this happen?
Why do you want to work with RGG?
I mean, I'm a big fan of Sega.
that game since it first came out and you know to be
associated with such a great game playing sego since it
first came out team that they put together it's an amazing
you know feat for me so I'm happy to be a part of it now we
got to talk about what just announced in this trailer how's
tupac being a part of this you know we the Tupac estate and
my son and myself we work very closely together so it just
made sense to put him in this game because his likeness and
his spirit still lives on it made sense so connected to what
we doing so what Game looks insane.
I'm sure you got more surprises in there too.
I know the song sounds great.
Well, we're looking forward to hearing more on Strange and
Heaven.
It just made sense to you guys.
I also want to ask you though about something a couple years
ago at TGA, you and Cordell talked about death row games,
something that you guys want to do.
Any updates on what's happening there?
DRG?
Yes, sir.
Death row games, you know, we're building a hip hop gaming
universe, bringing an authentic culture to life.
So awesome.
We just got a lot of plans that we plan on actually bring it
to life in the next couple of months.
Okay.
well we'll uh hopefully hear more on that soon yes sir yes
sir thank you for joining us thank you all thank you thank
you thank you wow somehow more crazy stuff to come all right
next we're excited to announce the new studio in sweden hex
is an open world action adventure game from key creators
behind the division and little nightmares oh you brave the
wild north as researchers stranded in a mind-bending
player-shaped procedural world.
This is a very cool game.
Take a look.
Oh god.
This is terrifying.
Whoa.
you whoa oh no I'm really bad at those
sorry the way he jumped was so goofy nice
close enough this is half life three everybody it looks it
feels like death stranding like that kind of same aesthetic
half life HA half three the three lines I got it yeah
tell if it's multiplayer or I guess it looks almost it looks
multiplayer like it looks I
can't wait to see more from hex it looks absolutely stunning
we have much more SGF to come but first on June 14th dead by
daylight is celebrating its 10th anniversary anniversary.
Watch this closely because here's a little tease of what's
ahead.
Jigsaw.
Do you want to play a game?
That's why he's there.
I'm free.
Happy birthday.
Oh, because it's their 10th anniversary.
That's so cute.
I breathe.
I tried breathing in it.
Live for the barn.
Oh.
Are you one?
Are you two?
Are you three?
Are you four?
Is it it?
Is it in the game?
You're invited.
Who on are you now?
I'm 19.
Mortal Shell 2.
Oh, dang.
If the bard was like...
Can you start every stream like Jigsaw?
Do you want to play a game?
Oh!
That guy was...
What is...
That guy would be twitching.
The trailer...
It almost looked like the lady Demetrisky or whatever.
Sitting at the table.
Like, the lady at the end looked like her outfit.
But the other people were wearing masks, which reminds me of
the strangers.
I'm doing Analysis, I'm doing analysis.
But she wasn't big, she just looked like she was wearing the
outfit.
Whoa, whoa!
Battleships, but...
Not.
Red Dead Redemption 3.
Sand.
Oh man, we were just talking about that.
We were just talking about that.
Pirates.
Pirateeering?
Is it dangerous?
Wouldn't pay so nice if it weren't.
Oh, does it pay?
I mean, like, well, I guess it depends on how much you loot
and plunder, right?
Assassin's Creed!
Pirates!
Wait.
Would if?
Assassin's Creed Pirates?
flag we don't think is that was there already an assassin
creed pirate oh there he is there he is oh my god he's
climbing like he does away from the grandest prize of all
after you captain
Black Flag is actually a great game.
Oh.
Sorry, I can't help being in the fourth dimension.
I'm so sorry.
Black Flag resynced, which is arriving.
Everybody, we're stuck in the fourth dimension.
I can't control the time.
One of the best action game developers in the world.
With a legendary franchise.
Half-Life?
You can't say legendary.
We have many expectations.
You can't say legendary franchise.
Oh, Rising 2.
Wait a second.
Toidels.
Toys.
Oh my God.
You guys having fun yet?
Yeah.
We are just getting started, believe it or not.
Platinum game, TMNT game though.
Now, please welcome two-time TGA loser for Expedition 33 and
Final Fantasy 16.
It's Ben Star who voices the visitor in Fortnite.
He just called him a loser.
Jeff.
Hello, Summer Game Fest.
For the past little while, I have had the incredible
opportunity to step into the world of Fortnite.
Jeff is so rude.
Why would you call him a loser in front of everybody?
And today, I finally get to share a glimpse of where that
journey is heading next.
Oh, hell.
King of the losers.
We've been working on this for a long time.
A new season is about to begin.
is about to change let me show you what's coming in
fortnite's next season runners launching later tonight i
don't want to see what's happening in fortnite i actually
don't want to see what's happening in fortnite the hunt for
power breeds chaos do the skip button i'm trying i'm trying
with these sprites creatures born from zero point energy
little animal mask gods.
They make you faster.
And dangerous.
Do the thing, Vito.
I'm trying.
So we must secure them.
I'm just gonna talk and sing through this because I'm
worried that Fortnite will have copyright and music and that
they will take my stream down and they'll be like, oh my
God, it's Fortnite.
We own your whole soul and all of us things on your channel
because we are Fortnite and we own every...
Did I do it?
They're like, hey, hey, ghost, you... Oh, John Wick!
Wait, John Wick.
Oh, God, when did they get married?
Sorry.
I said John Wick, you guys.
if you're wondering how we end up on this new island you'll
have to jump into the yeah audio is off again you've inside
fortnight right after summer game fest this i'm gonna
restart i'm gonna refresh okay wait that was a key this
season we asked every player to choose a sign never mind
it's not me it's them live event that choice changes your
experience it has all been building to this moment they're
sabotaging him but the doors open early and trust me your to
stay to the very end of the event i've got a little surprise
waiting for you oh the stage is set you chose your side i
wonder when it'll refresh i remember when fortnite was a
zombie horde defense game wait was it ever actually was it
actually ever
It was?
Now it's time for a special announcement from Bandai Namco
about one of the most influential sci-fi franchises ever
created.
Bandai Namco!
When I checked into the hotel, because they got us our
hotels, right, for the Ace Combat event?
They were like, oh yes, your company Bandai Namco paid
for...
your entire room and i was like my company band-aid napco my
company band-aid napco
it was awesome oh my gosh when will the audio resync hold on
i'm gonna try doing like the playback thing again
is this armored core every breath taken is inside an armor
shell
Gundam?
The darkness coming for us.
Not I'm recording.
It remembers one man.
Gundam?
Like actually?
If not Gundam, that was the most Gundam design I've ever
seen.
Oh!
Wow!
Oh my god.
God!
I'm here.
Thousands of games launch every year.
Some Gundam people probably recognize that guy.
That's why I'm launching my new newsletter, Looking for
Game.
Looking for Game.
Me.
I'm looking for Game.
I'll be curating and selecting games that deserve your
attention every week and sending demos and exclusive
playtest invites straight to your inbox.
Demos are nice.
Head over to lookingfor.game to sign up with playit.gg.
Speaking of fun, unexpected games, this next title comes
from a solo developer, Adrián Mulero from Spain.
It is a co-op physics game about two geeks and one very
fragile egg.
Eggie.
Okay, honky.
Ready to be a parent?
Sure, don't worry.
This is a piece of cake.
Oh no!
Be careful, be careful with our little baby.
Don't drop it, don't drop it.
Oh my god, they're back there.
Be careful.
Be careful with our little baby.
Oh wait, we're YouTube pooping again.
Don't drop it.
Careful.
Don't laugh.
Left.
Your other left.
Okay, new plan.
This is a good one.
Are you listening to me?
Um, Bloodborne 2?
Bloodborne 2?
It's way too hard.
Bloodborne 3?
Watch out with our baby.
Watch out with our baby!
My baby!
Oh.
Oh, I can't tell if it's skipping or if the trailer is doing
really hard maybe if we look for some more people It would
be easier More people wait why why are we?
This really is an extremely hard game
Congrats Adrian what a fun game All right now it is time for
a debut game from a veteran team of developers who come from
naughty dog and infinity ward and an other amazing studios
over the past half decade they've quietly been working on an
ambitious new project here is the global announcement oh
people are endlessly disappointing they're grady
they're cruel was that Barney they lie they're bullies Hey,
Snooks?
Yeah, I got one of them.
Say this is Ghost?
So that's what I say when I look at someone like you.
Bullying.
See, that's why we're different.
I genuinely like most people.
Oh, well then you're truly a sick fuck.
That's no moon!
We need the move.
I'll be coming for you.
Coming for us.
That's no good.
That's a...
That's...
That's Pluto.
That's what they said when...
Wait, no, Pluto was a planet.
You guys don't understand the real threat.
Not like we did.
Oh!
Boom!
Headshot!
Oh, get shooting at.
No!
What the heck is that?
Either we, fight those things together or die alone.
Eww.
No, do not touch him.
He's a bomb!
He's gonna explode!
We fight together.
Or die alone.
Oh.
Liquid gold.
I thought it was called That Snow Moon.
It's called Crossfire.
What's that Snow Moon?
For over 18 years, Jacob and I have developed
character-driven games.
With the goal of thoroughly connecting design and story.
In Crossfire, two opposing operators must Yes, it's the
studio.
Depending on one another is their only chance of survival.
To support this narrative, we completely rethought how cover
and traversal work together and created a system that
rewards tactical thinking, stealth, and repositioning.
It's called adaptive cover.
With adaptive cover, our player character, Layla,
dynamically adjusts her stance to react to the complex
terrain and the enemy's line of sight.
It fundamentally changes your relationship with the
environment and becomes an active skill to master.
Shout out to our amazing team at That's the Moon who are
meticulously crafting Crossfire.
It's for all of you who, like us, love high agency, single
player story driven games.
Thank you.
Amazing.
Thank you so much, Jacob and Taylor.
Now, last year at the Game Awards, we introduced the next
game from Remedy Entertainment.
Turn the board game into a video game.
Here's a new look at the mind-bending world.
The game would have been 10 out of 10 if the male character
had that man's face layer.
Right?
Missed opportunity.
It's been seven years.
The oldest house has fallen.
Everything we tried to contain is now loose in the streets
of Manhattan.
Oh, is this a...
Control, right?
It's caused by a new type of hostile resonance.
I'm not paying attention.
It's all...
I'm not listening.
And fascinating.
I'm looking down.
Whoa!
What?
A bob!
Oh my god!
This is sick!
I can't look because I haven't played Control-1.
Keep searching for the solutions in every way we can.
I have to, I have to, I also haven't played Alan Wake too.
I gotta get through all of them.
Wait, isn't it control in between Alan Wake technically?
Before it's too late.
Alan Wake too, I'm in.
Yee!
Right now it's time for another Summer Game Fest exclusive.
The announcement of the next name.
I don't remember the song.
In a story franchise.
Story franchise.
It's Ray Man again.
We all have our own reasons for coming to this vast
frontier.
The studio that brought you...
One of the most exhaustingly detailed and rewarding MMOs in
existence?
Modern evolution of runescape!
Wonder at the astonishing power that shapes this land.
Guild Wars.
Oh geez, Guild Wars.
At the great spirits to whom we are bound.
at the gods who hold dominion over I've had friends that
were really into guild wars and tried to get me into guild
wars and they were like they were like you have to play
guild wars because even your safety we are we will not hang
out because I'm too busy playing guild wars so if you want
to hang out and still be friends we have to you have to play
guild wars for a cause worth dying for to promise.
Matches.
Three!
Guild Wars!
Ah!
It's everyone watching both here and live online around the
world.
We got it!
I'm Colin Johansson.
The studio headed arena net.
Hi.
Colin Johansson.
And I want to thank you for watching the exclusive first
look at our upcoming game.
The time is right for the next evolution of the MMORPG.
And that game.
is Guild Wars 3.
Oh, man.
By taking the photo.
Glad you all agree.
Guild Wars 3 is an epic world that is both beautiful and fun
to explore, where the joy of movement is powered by your
character's momentum and combat will usher in an entirely
new type of MMO experience.
The way the camera was moving for a second?
By launching on PC and PlayStation 5, we're inviting the
biggest audience yet to experience treadmill stage he's just
slipping and sliding to welcome all of you to join our guild
wars they beat the curse of three go to guild wars three you
gotta say goodbye to your friends forever now goodbye my
boo goodbye thanks colin get ready to blast across the
galaxy with daring races dangerous rivals and some very
familiar faces star wars galactic racer is coming this
october to a brand new planet, Dervan Akos.
Now this is Pod Racing.
Pod Racing.
Why didn't they have them introduce it?
Welcome to Dervan Akos.
Peep-a-bap-a-bap.
Where champions are born and losers.
There's that guy that was on the stage before.
What was his name?
Oh, I love that we got a beep-pap-pap-pap-pap mention.
Star Wars!
I collapsed when I saw him.
Stay out of my way.
Oh, this is the dream shade.
sorry i went back in time again i had to see it twice wait i
had to see it i had to see it three times so sorry
one more time bring it back boys Quit abusing the Force of
Six!
Rewind feature!
October!
Everything is October!
Everything is September and October.
I fear for everybody's wallets, truly.
What's this guy?
I think the audio is...
is desynced again.
Everyone's desperate to get their games before GTA is sick.
End of Abyss.
Yeah, I was gonna say it looks like Little Nightmares.
It's epic games though.
But it looks so interesting.
Submarco!
Is this raft 3?
Yeah.
Raft 2.
Maybe.
Was there a raft 2?
Everything is... Oh.
I don't think so.
Me thinks this is not raft.
Unless?
I didn't get that far in the game to know if there were mer
people.
Zombies.
Raffed to the rot.
Last Arbor.
That looks interesting.
Definitely different.
I love me a good fishing game.
Fishing horror is all the rage.
Sega's plans to bring back many of its classic franchises,
including Jet Set Radio and Crazy Taxi.
Uh-huh.
Another one is Virtua Fighter.
Today we've got your first ever look at the surprising scale
and scope of the next installment this is virtual fighter
crossroads sorry that the audio is desynced
oh okay this might be copyrighted so i'm gonna yell over it
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm gonna say my own words to that
youtube doesn't feel like they have to take my stream down
i'm only watching this it's their fault they should have
their stream taken down instead of me not the one hosting
and using the audio your sister's really taking this whole
job thing seriously huh divina oh i know it's so decent holy
cow it's so bad otherwise we wouldn't be living in villa
support I can try again, hold on.
Hey, it's me.
There he is.
Oh my god.
Oh, the mafia.
Sorry.
I'm so sorry, guys.
I'm trying to get it back on track.
Oh my god.
Take it easy.
I'll try refreshing towards the end Oh Oh
That's Your Your Mom Your mom You play the part of a fighter
But You are lacking in Kung Fu Rise Over the Okay While the
While the copyright music may be playing, I'm gonna refresh.
I'm so sorry, I feel like...
I...
I'm gonna try...
What if I like...
I don't even know when it went to 4K.
I'll do...
Stop saying the song, please!
It's still not.
I give up.
I give up!
I don't think it's me, I think it's them.
Who knows though?
It's been 25 years since RuneScape was born, and 20 years
tomorrow that Durial 321 wreaked havoc in Fallador.
Finally, this legendary universe is coming to console with
RuneScape Dragon Wilds, playable now on PC and early access.
Here's a new look.
More RuneScape!
Few survive the land of dragons.
but some seek more than survival i think i remember or
rather i remember being into runescape for like i was
hardcore into it for like six months into the unknown
claiming dominion and forging their legend
stylistic to look this way oh yeah yeah the uh The D-Sync,
yeah, it's that...
Oh, he's so chill on his magic carpet.
Just so...
He has no...
He has no worries, no problems, no places to be.
September!
Oh my god, Square Enix mentioned.
Oh my god!
That was it.
That's all we'll see of them, maybe.
Nintendo Switch.
In the ebbing spring.
The skies will clot.
No.
Our shedding seeds make piles of rot.
Eww.
Odians cast with tempers rare.
In the ebbing spring.
Red Minos squirm.
tainted claire three virtues nice parry not all we cast for
us
fk in the coffee whoa find me that's a design for
soul frame preludes
i see frame is fine yeah it's okay they're not actually
monsters we're just oh um uh what was this game called i
can't remember grounded hey guys you're gonna want to see
this please tell me that was your stomach hold on to your
buggies It's like...
It's like...
It's just Earth Defense Force.
Crazy Earth Defense Force.
Honey, I shrunk the kids.
What the hell did we get ourselves into?
Oh, how cute!
Oh, so cute!
Grounded two!
Whoa!
Lizard.
Do you think there will be any Deadly Premonition updates?
Let it ride on a roll of the dice.
Lazard.
No.
What if there is Deadly Premonition 3, you guys?
I'm calling it.
Deadly Premonition 3.
FK in the coffee.
When the cards are on the table.
Mafia.
The old country.
I'm a level 100 mafia boss.
Yes, that was indeed a young Don Salieri from the original
Mafia.
Man of Honor expands Enzo's journey in Mafia, the old
country.
Enzo?
Manchini?
Okay, can you imagine working on something for 16 years of
your life?
Yeah, obviously.
Back in 2010, the creator of Assassin's Creed.
Oh, set out on a journey to build his next time bending
epic.
Oh, today after many twists just like this stream is finally
time for Patrice Desolais to invite you in.
Desolais you a Patrice you have you have warped the you have
warped time to
It's going out of hand I was born to be the collector To
protect a world I cannot be a part of
too strong it is my fate oh cool visual I have devoted my
life to facing them those granted the power to raise those
corrupted by their gifts tilting the ancient balance toward
cataclysm is she a witch for real but it last I meant hot in
the thumbnail that day what do you mean yeah yeah stop
which which every choice every breath which has led me to
this moment as the moon bears witness I take the first step
my time which is great i am ready one six one one six six
six amsterdam
1666 has been a monumental and emotional journey david lynch
once said the film is the talking That's all I feel today
about the game.
Instead of explaining features, I'll simply say this.
As of right now, the prologue is free to download on Steam
and Epic Games Store.
I don't know if I'll stream it, but I kind of want to play
it.
It's a 30-minute story experience in a Miss Bush, if you
will.
I'll leave you with a glimpse of what's to come when the
game launches on early access later this year.
30-minute prologue is cool.
Merci, en panache coalesce.
Thank you.
I've been thinking, oh my gosh, I want a black cat so bad.
The visuals are so, like, exactly what I love.
It feels so, like, like, what, something that I would really
like.
Thank you, Patrice.
Still to come, we've got a lot of great announcements for
you, including a special surprise guest.
It's like...
I can't believe they spoiled him.
Billy from Saw.
Hey, Billy.
Hello.
I want to play a game.
Oh, you want to play a game?
Well, that's great.
We're here at Summer Game Fest.
This is all about playing games.
This is all about games.
Roll the tape.
You heard the puppet.
They couldn't get Miss Piggy back so he went to jigsaw.
I think I might be obsessed with this though, depending.
Since the genesis of your roots, they call you a monster.
But I call you a prophet.
Prophet me?
So did this guy like die of brain cancer yet or what?
Isn't that the whole thing?
Wait, why are we at war?
What happened in the war?
Oh my god!
What really makes them tick?
Tick, tick, tick.
He died in Saw 3s and why are we on like 12?
Be paid in blood.
Oh,
this is like, uh...
yeah, it's some students.
Got it.
It had apprentices.
Yeah, this feels like Outlast Trials.
Your book, bound in blood.
If it's like that, then maybe not my style.
The spiral bleeds.
ever deeper let the game speak 3v1 multiplayer horror game
oh oh okay i'm gonna go get a tissue real quick i gotta boom
my nose we'll
be determined by one final sacrifice we are ready to bleed
bearer
the veil between rounds is unravelling.
This...
Lords of the Fallen 2.
That's right, Lords of the Fallen 2 is also coming to Steam
this fall.
Next up is a brand new game from Bitreactor, a studio formed
by some of the most experienced developers in the tactic
genre.
Roll the deck.
This is Star Wars Zero Company.
Sorry.
was just briefed on a separatist fleet massing in the
Ceralona system then we need to make our move you got
someone what do you got for me Penic what's Zillius coil's
been spotted meeting with local gangsters not the gangsters
I've been tracking father fronts she's at the center of it
all all right let's get it team together
every strike counts i heard the new mandalorian movie didn't
do so good though i thought i didn't even realize i thought
it oh this is not at all the gameplay i thought it was going
i thought it was um going to be like a disney plus thing and
then it turned into a full movie X-Cons and we're better for
X-Com.
We're almost there.
We just gotta finish this job.
There we go.
I'm one day away from retirement.
We just gotta do this last thing.
Oh no!
It's him!
Sand eater.
Dark fantasy has always been about one thing, the monster
within, and today one of Europe's most ambitious studios is
ready to take you into a brutal new world where vampires
have emerged.
I thought he said...
Oh no, Nimi.
Nimi heard vampire.
She has been activated.
I thought they said...
I thought they said Final Fantasy.
Oh man.
Vampire?
What?
Maybe this guy will survive.
Maybe not.
I think it's time to go.
I think it's...
Okay, he was smart to, like, you know, kick over the box,
but maybe...
Yeah, there you go.
Maybe a little too late.
You don't give up easy, eh?
Maybe he does survive.
You certainly have reasons to hate me.
Vampire.
Oh!
My son.
You've ruined my life.
We crave the same thing.
Blood.
Evil?
Am I evil?
They adore me.
You're a pawn in Brentice's hands.
Nothing more.
This won't end well for you.
I've done the unthinkable for my own family.
Sir, I need you to slack for that.
You could just buy blood.
It wasn't even in a pool or it didn't look like.
It was lukewarm.
Men!
It's nonsense.
Show!
the same blood the blood of Dawn Walker hello everyone my
name is Konrad Tomaschievich and I'm the game director of
the blood of Dawn Walker what you just saw was an invitation
to join us on an adventure adventure to auras and cultures
in our story-driven open-world dark fantasy saga the first
part another september launch it's kind of actually insane
how almost all of these games are september and october the
gameplay like quite literally is from our current it's it's
it's frightening story of kohen i hope you will have as much
fun playing our game as we had making it so much in
september so much in october thank you so what gta is the
end of this year supposedly they're avoiding gta Do we even
have a date for it?
Thanks, Conrad.
Next, the creators of Among Us have been hard at work on a
new project.
And today we're revealing it for the first time.
Yeah!
Omogos?
That's the shape of one.
A new standalone game.
It's a visual novel!
Omogos Vien!
A task to do!
Oh.
Is this a detective game?
Oh no.
Among us detective game.
Wait.
Whoever killed the cook has their own recipe for murder.
Story on guard!
Wait, when did that...
From the Among Us TV series, please welcome Yvette Nicole
Brown and Liv Houston.
Everybody out, like, watching this live, watch that thing
walk on stage and fall over.
Hello, Summer Game Fest!
Hi!
We are dead!
We are so excited about the future of Among Us as crew
members ourselves, our task is sharing... I recognize her
from community.
GTA 6 has been confirmed to release after 5, but Look, I
know fans have been dying for updates, but there's a dead
body right there.
And the imposter could be any one of us.
I think this calls for an emergency meeting.
So you'd rather call a meeting than complete our task?
That's suspicious.
I'll have to report this to Mira HQ.
Oh, no, I mean, I don't think there's any need.
Take it up with admin.
the moment you've all been waiting for what am i waiting for
actually chaos betrayal and more i'm actually not sure what
i'm waiting for series enjoy wait what emergency meetings
crewmates our fellow mates of crew half perished they would
have prepped are you talking so weird yeah but i just don't
understand why you're the official cause of death acute
ripping off of the face oh that crewmate that's an oopsie
Three makes it a murder mystery.
There's a show.
Was it you?
Whoever smelted Delta.
If only there was someone who could take charge.
Since one.
I was a lot of screaming.
Elijah would?
She would.
Fill of R.
Zion.
Black.
And I'm rare.
The hot one.
What's back there?
Oh, wow.
We have to kill the imposter.
We're so happy to have you among us.
Or is it amongst us?
I'll always forget.
Would you believe me if I said some of our biggest surprises
at SGF are still to come?
Stay tuned.
And it turns out there's more coming.
I'm believing in you.
One of this year's best reviewed games, 007 First Light.
Stop posting about Among Us.
Of a new story mission coming later this year.
I think I'll probably watch the Among Us anime.
I think I'll probably watch it.
Go back to Aleph and find out what this is all about.
Best of luck.
Oh, I heard really good things about that though.
I kind of want to play it.
I saw, like, Doki was saying, it's her, like, game of the
year, but I can't tell if she's being serious.
Oh, my gosh, Square Enix!
It's really good.
It's a fun game.
I kind of... I heard it was kind of janky.
Like, I watched Limu play a little bit of it.
And, um...
But, so I want to play it before they patch it.
Brothers, the time is finally here.
I know it's been difficult all these years a lot of fantasy
stuff I'm getting I'm getting like fantasy like my eyes
glaze over a little bit by it you know so much fantasy
gothic remake someone was really excited
your cup of tea then you're probably so happy dang she was
cute cute girl
owl this looks adamant as hell what is this is this already
think like already franchise it must be right this isn't it
might not be a new thing Very Korean, right?
The animals are fine.
Orangutan.
It's a Korean MMO.
Take flight.
Reminds me of the flight things in Sonic, not Sonic, sorry,
spiral.
Atreya.
Elites.
Oh my god, she's so pretty though.
I am.
I am too.
I'm looking to find the source of the disturbance and end
it.
To do that.
More anime!
Wait a...
Anime!
Maybe this is all a brain dance.
A simulation?
Cyberpunk?
Oh, it is Cyberpunk!
Maybe the two of you really are from another universe.
Wait!
They're making a game out of the anime?
Or...
Is it a collab?
Delete in your ass.
It's a collab.
Oh.
I can feel it.
That nightmare test of discord is looking for us.
I see.
Oh, weathering webs.
I know nothing about it.
like Wuthering Waves and those kinds of games.
I don't know anything about them.
That was a look at what's ahead for Wuthering Waves and its
collab with Cyberpunk Edge Runners on June 8th.
Now, if you want to track all the games shown today, head to
player.g list your favorites across all platforms.
Right now, it's time for news on a massive expansion coming
to a franchise that has been on this stage before.
Yeah.
Mom, you can't say that's...
Oh, chat, Frozo.
Thank you.
Wiferia negated the weight of buildings and mounted the sky.
I can't stop wondering, how can all this exist up amongst
the clouds?
Wow!
We hunted?
Oh my gosh!
Hello, Dante?
What?
Don't forget to grab your sword!
He's got his red coat and everything.
Yeah.
We're Nero.
Yeah, we're Nero now.
Exactly.
A natural disaster.
Too powerful to tame.
Too difficult to reproduce.
Sorry.
I said Dante because of the red coat.
Because every time I see red coat, I think of Dante.
Game where you kill dinosaurs.
They're not... No, you hunt.
Specifically, you hunt the monsters.
That is a very important part.
If you are ever sponsored by Monster Hunter, you are not
allowed to say kill.
You are specifically instructed to say, I am hunting the
monsters.
Ooh, massive expansion.
Cool.
You know it's all for nothing.
Still, you press on.
Hello.
He's gotta get his shirt on.
He's got it.
Maybe?
Not.
Oh, it's someone else's shirt.
We tried to decode this guy.
My bad.
We almost took your clothes!
I'm so sorry!
Hellbirds!
Oh yeah.
This guy's got too many tricks.
Oh, I thought his name said Master of Catnip.
I was like, where's your cat?
If you're the Master of Catnip.
You can see it.
Whoa!
Our summon is crazy.
Oh.
Wait, did that hit?
I couldn't really do that.
He's shielding us!
Phase two.
Oh, that was a cool way to end the trailer.
That was pretty cool.
Swords of Legend Take your time Enjoy Hmm That was a new
look at gameplay From Swords of Legend A fantasy action RPG
There you saw a boss fight against Kong Kong Ji With each
move pulled from real centuries old Chinese magic tradition
Now how about a little toy car magic Get ready for lots of
loop-de-loops with the announcement of the biggest Hot
Wheels racing game yet.
Hot Wheels?
Yeah!
I love when you can hear someone so excited in the audience.
Whoa!
She said lots of loop-de-loops, but I see one.
You wouldn't lie to me, would you?
Forzo!
No!
Yeah, we even got King Kong.
He's just chilling up there.
In-in-engine footage.
So the ducks...
Alright.
Wow, cars.
Oh no!
So can we see the loop-de-loop happen or... Oh, there's
There's one in the background.
Oh, there's a couple.
Oh, are we gonna see it?
Oh!
Wait, they took us to a- oh!
I wanna see a loop-de-loop!
I was promised!
Zoomershyper, welcome to membership!
Thank you!
Infinite rush!
Sega!
Sonic!
Betty!
Avatar!
Oh!
Oh no!
Sonic!
I was about to say, is this Pico part?
Oh no, Vicky!
Oh no!
Oh my god!
is this why they delisted the uh original pico park happy
anniversary sonic i saw the warning and i was like that
can't be ava but i can't believe it was that depicts the
entire story of a famous anime from beginning to end
dedicate your heart to this what is the dedicated you can
dedicate your heart oh is
this a muso Wait.
Is this a...
No, is this attack on Titan Muso game?
And it goes through the whole story?
Or rather...
I got to season...
It was like, I watched everything up until that really,
really long break.
So I didn't get to finish the series.
Spoilers, I guess.
Finale spoilers, yeah.
Oh, I guess...
Three!
I guess they have the...
Wait, but...
From many of the creative leaders behind Forza Horizon comes
a new cinematic open world driving experience.
Set in Monaco and the French Riviera, where the worlds of
pro and underground street racing I'm a pro.
This is Clutch from Maverick Games.
Maverick.
Clutch.
Just stop using the music.
The cure of racing.
For real though.
Oh gosh.
Three more in intensive care.
They didn't.
They didn't clutch.
My friend said you can me some people are meant to be
outlaws Theo where's wait about it ever we're racing now
should have clutched I thought that so it's open world I did
all that for you to get out of trouble now I'm in deeper
than when I start they're showing like way more story than I
mean an open world still mean story but like you what i mean
i thought it was just racing i can't be taking risk like
this i'm a lead driver in the r1k oh my god oh my god he's
blowing stuff up i'm not going to jail for you
why The dead won't rise.
But their sons...
Ah!
Half-Life 3?
Half-Life 3 is the prologue.
One.
All the way back in medieval times.
Age of Empires!
Wait.
Dear...
I almost sang this yesterday!
I had it on my list!
Don't fear the Reaper.
That's crazy.
I should have done it.
Where's the elephant?
All hell!
King of the losers!
Yeah.
I think it's so funny watching all the little guys.
Chronicles Medieval.
Watching all the little guys run out of each other is so
funny.
It's just like, it's so funny watching like Civil War
reenactments because they like take turns.
And trust me, trust me, you definitely will want to stick
around.
Right now, here's a new look at Sea of Remnants from
Nette's.
I'm trusting you.
Wake up laughing, have a miss, wrong direction, no regrets.
Every face feels out of line, that's how I know they're all
mine.
We don't fit and we don't care.
I like her outfit.
Oh, she's so cute.
I'm so confused what this game is.
I'm just watching a music video.
Is it gotcha?
Maybe.
I don't dislike the art style.
I think it's, you know, I can appreciate its stylistic.
But I'm not, I, what's the game?
Gosh!
Like they were running around in the wild.
I'm sorry.
Is it?
What's it called?
It looks like, um...
What's the list?
In a world.
In a room.
On a shelf.
Dante.
Dante!
Uh, guys, is it me or is there something off with this one?
yeah he seems different has he always had that mustache he
doesn't have a mustache oh yeah hey buddy what's your deal
howdy names Ryu what's all this mess about me being
different well look at that howdy my name is Ryu everyone in
Tokyo talks like this I know what this is it's called a
knockoff well our nation could a knockoff do this howdy
Howdy dookin?
The Capcom summer game sale is here.
Take home genuine, bona fide, 100% authentic real deals on
select titles.
You're not a boss.
I can't do it if you're watching.
Uh-huh.
Ladies and gentlemen, representing the trailer for the sale.
Howdy dookin!
It's too good!
It's so good!
It's too good.
Hit man!
Black and yellow.
What?
Where's Khalifa?
There's singing celebrities and everything nowadays.
No, not Pokemon.
Halvers?
Pal world Wait, pal world Not pal birds Pal world I didn't
know if this I didn't realize that people were so playing
this
Oh cute
There's dozens of us It's technically not done yet.
Oh yeah, that's right.
I wonder if this is the official release then.
Nice save.
How world?
One point!
Oh!
Oh my god, it's happening!
It's happening!
Jala- Oh my gosh, it's not September or October.
Power World 1.0 is coming out on July 10th.
Now at the start of the show, I mentioned we'll have lots of
new worlds to explore today and the return of some long
awaited ones as well.
This next game falls into that last category.
Jeff.
It's been a long, long, long eight years.
homicide six total shot the threat no I manifested in
everybody you're so welcome order on the precinct is you're
living under a rock you were raging dumpster file of a
person you're the reason i'm here she's uh oh my god it's
happening no all of us do mr toad returns please have mr
toad in hell guys we will be playing it 2027 oh what do you
mean what do you mean by
what is this?
I don't think it's a the game doesn't need a remaster what
What?
No way.
You did it again.
That's right.
Big B is finally back.
Big B.
And as we wait for his new adventure in 2027, check out the
Wolf of Among Us remastered this holiday.
This next game comes from an acclaimed studio that is deep
into development on its next project.
I just finished that game.
That's so crazy.
You're timing.
Wow.
The choice is blank.
This choice is blank.
I'll see about playing.
Maybe we play the remaster on stream, since I can make
totally different decisions in all, right?
Well, chat's frozen.
Thank you.
Cute!
Wait, Stellar Blade?
I've been listening to the OST recently.
Is the game good?
Because I'm kind of really interested in it.
Stop saying weird things.
Okay, take it easy.
It's really good?
Initiating C-3 sync.
Ready, Angel.
Roger, Kana.
Tracking.
I like the music of it a lot, so...
How's it looking out there?
I can't stand crowds.
They'd be better for both of us if we got out of here
quickly.
In the movies, this is always where things go wrong.
Hey.
Well, I'm just saying.
It's a cliche.
Wait, the target stopped.
This is like the Resident Evil Requiem opening sequence
where you're following that guy as Leon in the city.
And he starts turning everybody into zombies.
She's so cute.
Hi Ryden.
My name is Sexy Ryden.
Whoa!
Yeah!
That's my...
That's something I like!
That pertains to my interests.
Stellar Blade!
Blood Red.
That was a good one.
Shift Up is returning to the world of Stellar Blade with an
all-new sequel developed entirely by the original team
that's here today, set in the same universe as Stellar
Blade.
This next chapter continues the story beyond the events of
the first game, introducing a new protagonist who you saw
there, Evie.
It's early in development and we will have more to share in
the future.
Thanks, Jeff.
We're almost done.
No.
Not quite.
It's been almost exactly three years since Street Fighter 6
was released in June 2023.
What's ahead?
This is Street Fighter 6 Year 4.
Year 4.
We the NECA sims had a hand in funding.
It's already entering Year 4.
But I can sense that we already have new challengers on the
horizon.
Hello.
That was me.
Howdy duken.
Fascinating.
Street Fighter.
What?
Tifa?
Final Fantasy VII Remake information, please.
Wait, does that mean?
Please welcome to the SGF stage.
Miyama-san, director of Street Fighter VI, and
Hamaguchi-san, director of Square Enix.
Thank you all of you.
Street Fighter VI has been a three-year-old.
Thank you.
Thanks to all of you, Street Fighter VI has reached its
third anniversary.
And today, we are announcing this special collaboration with
Final Fantasy.
Tifa is a character loved by the players all around the
world.
That's exactly why our goal was this.
To bring to life a Tifa could truly fight within the world
of Street Fighter VI.
They have a dress code.
They all go to the same barber.
Everything from her design to movement has been rebuilt as
Tifa, the street fighter.
It's the squeenix haircut.
Kutera has also been reimagined as a new gameplay system.
It's great.
It's not negative.
It's an iconic Final Fantasy element to the battle
experience.
Tifa's fight is far from over.
We hope you all look forward to what's coming next.
Thank you to Hamaguchi-san and Nakayama-san for coming all
the way from Japan and join us for that special moment on
stage.
Then we'll see you guys again later this year.
All right.
Well, now it has come time for our final announcement.
What?
No!
What's it going to be, guys?
Any guesses?
No, and frankly, I don't know what I could say to set this
moment up besides this.
Get ready for the final battle.
Long ago, a shadow fell upon our planet.
Guided by calamity, one man sought dominion through reunion.
Oh, ah, yippee!
A meteor!
Yippee!
But our planet answered.
Awakening mighty motions to stand against this celestial
planet.
Now, hope endures in those who fight.
Long story short, the world's in trouble.
It has been for a while.
So what are we waiting for?
Four, let's give Sephiroth the beating of a lifetime.
Yippee!
Don't say September.
Don't say October.
Guys, there is no GTA.
I'll make this quick.
Good night, sweet thing.
The sky's the limit!
I can do this.
I'll make you proud.
Nice outfit.
Oh my, is that a weapon I see?
I know Sid's so cool.
He's so 30.
Let us put your faith to the test.
Show more Caitlin.
Revelation!
I never would have made it this far without you guys.
And I won't let you down.
I promise.
There was no Aerith.
There you have it.
And no, he's not done yet.
Please join me in welcoming back to Summer Game Fest, the
director of Final Fantasy VII, Revelation, Naoki,
Amaguchi-san.
Yeah.
No, you guys remember the end of Part 2.
He was still hallucinating her.
That'll be the Revelation.
I'm truly delighted to unveil Final Fantasy 7 Revelation,
which is launching simultaneously on all platforms.
Oh!
And we've only been able to come this far thanks to every
single one of you who continued to believe in the story and
waited for this moment with us.
I waited for Caitlin!
So it is the last part.
The central theme of this title is Resolve.
Cloud and his companions each confront their own destinies
and find the resolve.
to march towards the final battle.
This game will be just like Doom.
I too have carried a promise in my heart throughout this
journey, the resolve to see the series through to its very
end.
We're committed to delivering this experience in its
ultimate form.
Please stay with us and witness.
what lies beyond that resolve today to help guide us on our
path please show me in welcome to the stage the voice the
voice of the voice Vincent Valentine Thank
You very much Hamaguchi Sun it's truly a privilege to be
here with you honestly so much to see in revelation i think
we just kind of need to dive right in what do you say let's
do it take it away matt
as we reunite with our heroes the meteor looms in the skies
above constant reminder of your mission and the grave
threats you'll confront as you embark upon your journey and
face the epic conclusion of the remake series wind your very
own airship and the pride of the Shinra fleet you'll take to
the skies and witness our most expansive open world yet from
the outskirts of Midgar to the Sun drenched Medill
archipelago to the warrior nation of Wutai simply pick a
direction and set sail but how can you be expected to
protect the whole world at once you'll need to cover yeah
they'll definitely kiss in this one cloud and Sephiroth no
way no how don't worry these parachutes are top of the
You'll be blown through the air like a feather.
I want to see your teeth.
And take a leap of faith.
With the wind rushing past, you'll descend seamlessly from
the sky above to the ground below.
Where will the winds guide you first?
That freedom is in your hands.
But no matter your destination, to defeat your enemy, you'll
need a fighting chance.
And that starts with your trusted allies.
At long last, with the world teetering on a blade's edge,
everyone assembles a cloud-sized, forming an epic ensemble
of heroes.
Where are we dropping, Cloud?
Each with a lone story that brings you closer together than
ever.
But a good unit needs more than friendship to save the day.
It needs a disciplined combat regiment.
The hybrid battle system established in Remake and refined
in Rebirth is perfected in Revelation.
Yeah, kill that bird.
Put even more power in your hands.
switch between party members to even the odds.
Then, when the fight calls for strategy, enter tactical mode
to unleash a suite of powerful new spells and abilities.
Activate devastating synergies with your companions.
Throw that Tifa.
And of course, call on mighty summoned entities that can
turn the tide of battle.
Yeah, but I want to know more about the story.
I don't want to know more about the story.
Summoning Efrid never gets gets old.
There are truly some chill-inducing fights ahead in
Revelation.
I'm so excited to see all of your reactions.
It's going to be amazing.
No spoilers.
I'm guessing you have a favorite character to frame battles.
Caitlin.
I might be a little biased, but since you brought it up,
let's have a look at our newest coffin-dwelling companion,
DC Valentine.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
I won't return to my coffin Until we've put Sephiroth in
case Vincent is a deft gunslinger Capable of delivering
precise high-yield shots But there's more to this secretive
former Turk than meets the eye The result of experimentation
at the hands of Shinra Vincent can transform into the
galleon beast At the press of a weapon He's getting
tremendous power It's overkill It's a bird It's a bird!
It's just a bird!
The Leap and Lancer, the Dash and Dragoon, the one and only,
Sid Highwind!
Sid Highwind, a cantankerous pilot extraordinaire, joins the
party.
They hate birds!
Sid's command of his lance allows him to rapidly close the
distance for powerful strikes.
Or engage in sweeping area of effect attacks to bring a
whole host of enemies to heal.
Battlefield.
Skills with a weapon only gets you so far.
To further augment your combat capabilities, try this on for
some reason.
Function integrated tactical suit wear, or the FITS system
for short, allows you to further customize your playstyle
with new uniforms and beauties unique movesets.
Alongside your equipment and materia, FITS gives you an
extra edge and bow.
To face what's coming, you'll need all the strength you must
have.
Help!
Staying your day.
Sensing its fate hanging in the balance.
Bits are so good!
The weapons, ancient beasts that are larger than life and
capable of untold destruction.
Will you be enough to stop them before it's too late?
I sure hope so.
As the world is torn apart, you and your friends must unite.
In Revelation, we come to the thrilling conclusion of the
Final Fantasy VII saga.
And your mission is clear.
Take up your Buster Sword.
Equip your materia and stand together.
We're so stylish.
Last time.
These skies belong to me.
Skies belong to me, not to a bird.
We hate birds.
More bird violence.
Well, thank you all.
Thank you, Hamaguchi-san, for bringing us this extended look
at Final Fantasy VII Revelation.
I think I speak for all of you.
us when i say we cannot wait to play it but matt yeah i
think we ended the video too early yeah i hate to leave a
story unfinished yeah is that right well then uh you better
take a look
more get the cannon back online now More?
Oh my god.
In
the mouth!
Oh.
At last, the promise is fulfilled.
The journey ends here.
Okay, good.
There's some time.
Yippee!
The three Final Fantasy VII, Revelation coming to all
platforms next spring, which is appropriate for today
because SGF is really a celebration of games across all
platforms.
Thank you to Hamaguchi-san, Kiru-san, and the team at Square
for that very special announcement.
And thanks to Lucy for a great job, Kosi.
Didn't she be great?
Thanks, Lucy.
Thanks, Jeff.
What an amazing way to end the show, but that's not all,
because coming up right now is Day of the Devs with a look
at many new independent game titles, including multiple new
game announcements.
That's right, tons of awesome indie games, so make sure to
stay tuned and watch that, and we will see you live this
August in Germany for Gamescom Opening Night Live, streaming
live on Tuesday, August 25th.
Until then, have a great summer, everybody.
Thanks for watching!
David F.
Starts right now!
Yippee!
Oh, bye!
Oh, no, it's not over.
Yes, five more Final Fantasy VII.
Finally, part three.
Caitlin.
I'm excited.
I don't know.
Two ended on such like a...
It ended so like...
I was like, I need to know.
I need to know where they are heading with this.
what i mean how far are we deviating half-life three and
gamescom they really were just like especially with the wolf
among us the way they were like oh people have been waiting
a really really really really really really long time i was
like wait a second this I was like there's no way I was like
there's no way there's no way but I can't move from muggles
and we got regular muggles I was crazy enough to 100% FF7
rebirth thanks to manifesting thanks for manifesting
revelation for me yeah you are crazy oh my gosh really
really Really, really, really long time.
Since you keep manifesting games, can you please play the
Sly Cooper series?
You can help Sly escape to Egypt purgatory.
I mean, I could try.
Can't believe they hid FF News in a YouTube poop.
I wrote.
What do you mean, though, Ace Combat today?
We got the most Ace Combat on Tuesday.
I think We'll need to have JRR Martin announce The release
of Half-Life 3 Yeah We also didn't get any Astro Bot That's
okay I did ask For that as well I was like Astro Bot
Something something or other But that's okay too Astro Bot
itself Is really great so Alright but I don't want to End
the stream just yet So some video games i picked out a
couple well they're a couple they're like two indie horror
games i was like i don't want to i don't want to just do a
watch along especially since i did a watch along the other
day um so i was like i don't want to just do a watch along
and then uh skedaddle um so i have some indie horror games i
picked out they're about an hour each we'll do two of them
Thank you!
Let me get them set up real quick.
But thanks for the watch along, everybody.
Thank you, thank you.
It wasn't a demo for the 1666.
I said it was like a 30-minute prologue.
I wonder if that means, though, if it's like playable or
like a movie.
confused by it I wonder I wonder thank you thank you thank
you thank you wait it's playable should we do that instead
it says demo on steam wait should we do that instead wait 16
16 but it's only a half hour right
every 333 three three three years something why why is
everything three everybody play the lottery and add three to
your number line i'm prophesizing right now i'd like to
thank me for playing the wolf among us and manifesting the
sequel i that is the one thing i did not expect at all that
was insane that was super duper crazy let's do it we'll do
the demo download the demo let's see The demo is 15 gigs.
Okay, install.
No lottery where I live, sadness.
No, I think that's better.
I think that's better.
When did I play Wolf Among Us?
It was, what, last month or something?
Right?
I'm checking, I'm checking, I'm checking.
I'm checking, I'm checking.
yeah like two weeks ago that's
insane imagine Minto finishes Half-Life 2 episode 2 and
Half-Life 3 gets announced no there's one more that I have
to play I have to play Alex oh Greg welcome to Mambusha
thank you I have to play Alex play Half-Life Alex.
Oh.
I'll try.
It can be modded to play without VR, but it's some work.
Right now, my VR, well, it's packed away.
But also, it had some issues.
So I basically i don't have my my my vr has not been
outputting music sound to my ears so like if i played the
game i would have to listen through my speakers it was very
strange i do get motion sickness but i'm willing to give it
a shot what model is it it's the valve index so you know
i've tried every i've you got i i if there was a solution
i've i've i've scoured the interwebs i have gone through
every reddit thread possible i i tried so i've tried so much
to fix it but um oh if it just downloaded um but uh um it
just my computer does not pick it up as like a as an audio
source for some reason.
But yeah, so it's okay.
It's all good.
I'll still, maybe it's something with, I'm wondering if it's
like something with my computer itself because it only
happened after I switched out some parts.
I don't know.
But because, I do get motion sickness, but I feel like
because I am not the worst with motion sickness usually,
with VR, I feel like maybe, maybe I could try it and there's
probably more people that haven't played it because of the
VR capabilities and like needing the VR and also the motion
sickness so I want to try and play it for like you know
anybody that watches me that would be able to experience it
we could all experience it together maybe for the first time
so I think it'd be fine as a as a as a group activity i
think it'd be fine if we all did it together wait should we
try the demo then for the the not demo the prologue of the
1666 amsterdam
can you wear earbuds with it with the with the with the with
the wow pop pop pop uh the the vr i don't know i don't think
so i don't think so yeah let's give it a shot okay hold on
i'm moving us over i'm moving us to the void welcome to the
void the void the void of shame
and silliness
Shame and silliness Okay, let me pull it up Wait, where did
it go?
Let me play Six, ten, there we go I'm worried that this game
is going to like Collapse my computer The graphics will be
like Too good I need my controller.
With the boop.
Okay.
I'm opening it.
Are my ears feeling better?
Yeah?
Oh, it's happening.
Yes.
Let's call this.
Yes and no.
Wait, hold on.
My goodness.
Hold on, Gim.
Oh my gosh.
I have frozen.
Oh, Shader.
a compilation in progress I might need to become a chibi for
this we might need to be chibi me too well let me I'll mess
with the graphics and see uh game capture I'm stood out
compilation will take about 15 minutes I don't think so
we're already on 30% 33 oh like why isn't it capturing
because there we go there we go uh and then i want to see
chat
oh my gosh wait oh my gosh i'm so sorry dr cranberry i just
saw the akasupa wolf among us to mr tow returns thank you so
much i'm so sorry maybe i read it but i was so like about i
was so like That I completely missed to say thank you so
much for that.
Okay, so thank you!
Yo-kichi!
Welcome to membership.
Hi, Minto!
Hello!
I think I read it, but I didn't say...
I'm so sorry.
I'm so rude!
I didn't say thank you!
Okay, you can punish me.
I accept...
I accept the punishment.
I read it.
I read it out loud, but it doesn't say thanks.
I'm so rude.
Mr. Toad.
I can't believe it's getting remastered, though.
I feel like it doesn't need to be.
Right?
Like, I feel...
The second game looks the exact...
Well, maybe if you don't want to be glitched.
Like I did.
Your punishment is to keep being ROC.
Ugh.
I don't know if I could do that.
I'm...
I'm lagging out you guys auto save warning this game is a
work of fiction I'm lagging out okay hold on I'm switching
to we're going champion mode everybody I'm lagging out I'm
lagging out what if I became the cat what if I became the
cat because this game has a cat in it
I played the game with the cat.
Okay, let's try.
Wait.
Even the cat lags.
No way.
Screen brightness.
I can't see anything.
Oh, just barely visible.
Wait, let me try something.
Let me try something for real.
I'll go to me.
To Chibiminto?
Chibiminto?
Aha!
Yeah!
She beat me through the best.
Okay.
Never mind.
I'm still lagging.
I like to put up the visibility just a little bit because
sometimes the...
Okay, subtitles on.
Streamer mode.
On.
What could that mean?
Please let me adjust the graphics.
Please.
To be the collector.
To protect a world I cannot be a part of.
Destined to be feared for what I am.
Close by.
Happy birthday!
I mean, game looks great.
I'm feeling...
I have devoted my life.
The game is working perfectly.
This is why when VTubers play games...
It's really hard to tell Like in the game like lags It's so
hard to tell If the game If it's the game's fault Or if it's
everything that's running in the background
Oh it is a cutscene I guess you're so right Well I mean like
it's not lagging But it could just be playing a video That
is low.
I miss my cat.
As the moon fares witness, I take the first step.
My time has come.
I am ready.
I'm shaking my head.
Can you tell?
Five, five FPS.
Display.
Please, please.
Oh my god!
Good golly!
You can make the resolution insane!
What should I go to?
Uh, what, um, I can never remember the numbers.
Chat is also lagging.
Everything is lagging!
Wait, the frame rate, yeah, it's locked at 30.
I wonder though.
The 7K is insane.
I feel like probably...
We'll go, we'll go with this.
Oh, save.
Wait, hold on.
It's going to get all funky for a second.
Wait.
The game just crashed.
An unreal process has crashed.
How about we play some indie horror games, guys?
I'm...
Uh, please provide details.
Um, game heavy and I change to 1080 and game go poof.
Send and close.
Hey!
I changed the cat V2 for it even that lagged.
The excellent bug report.
I'm helping them out.
Wait, I'll just say as a cheat me, it's fine.
So I have two games.
This first one is called Two Well Hidden.
And this is also making my computer go wackadoo.
The game is blank.
Oh, am I lagging again?
Wait, I don't need my controller.
Oh, yeah.
Wow, so spooky.
Wait, let me change this also.
I... Can I turn down, like, the...
Can I turn down the...
the effect?
It's crazy.
Oh, you guys can't see it.
My bad.
There we go.
Spooky sounds!
What does this mean?
Texture quality.
Normal?
Eighth size.
What the heck does that mean?
Controls.
Okay, it's pretty standard.
Look sensitivity.
We might need to adjust that later.
Spooky, spooky!
It is not a Chilla's game.
It's just...
I watch other streamers that play indie horror games.
And this one seemed interesting, so...
We're trying it out.
I feel like, though...
I guess this is fine.
I don't see...
Maybe if I apply it.
I'm not lagging.
I don't think we need the B60 FPS.
Okie dokie.
I'm smooth now.
Yeah.
Okay.
New game!
Oh, starting a new game will over- I don't have a game.
Yeah.
One FPS.
I'm pressing?
I'm so smooth.
Oh, I thought she said moi!
Whoa, oh my gosh, this effect though is like insane.
saying.
The sensitivity is kind of strange, but oh, animals!
The window is open.
Wait, I think I need to turn the sensitivity down.
Half, maybe?
Okay, that's a bit better.
Oh, geez.
My PT PTA looking house.
Hmm.
looks like a russian blue the cat yeah so are we i think
we're trying to find our sister who is counting hello i
can't open anything hello
oh my god why look at this effect i can't see anything
because it's so it's just so staticy I bet the frame rate is
going insane right now.
Or not frame rate.
The bit rate.
I'm afraid of the dark.
Can I turn it on?
Don't turn off the lights.
Oh.
Is that her family?
Holy gaming posture.
Also.
Look at this headbob.
Uh, Eda Reed.
I love playing hide and seek with my sister.
She has such sinister handwriting.
I try to find a good place, but she finds me so fast.
I don't think I'm very good at hiding.
Maybe tomorrow I'll find a place she can't find so quick.
Okay.
My sister has such scary handwriting.
writing.
Where are you doing all that running at?
Lock.
Locked.
Will this be horror or tragedy?
Oh.
I thought something changed there, but...
What the?
Oh, there's a girl!
Sister?
I don't know if this is actually going to be so scary or if
it's a little silly scary.
We'll see.
It might get us, you know?
Is there a light switch?
I'm scared.
Seems like a normal house so far.
The, uh, some of the...
Is that in here?
Where's that out here?
Wait, all the lights are flickering.
Wait, which lights are flickering?
Is it that one?
That one?
Stop that!
What is this?
Maybe this is the front door.
Nose for Roo, too.
Oh, this is the kitchen, I think.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Kitty kitty.
I thought that was like a potato.
The world's largest...
The texture of it...
Or not the texture, the pattern of it.
It made it look like a potato.
A little bit.
Wait, was the end of the hallway always so...
Like broken like that?
Is there another note here?
Oh no, it's the textures are being funky, I think.
I think it's the game.
I don't think it's like...
Actually, I can't tell.
World's largest potato.
Look, I'm not judging her hobbies.
I'm not judging her hobbies.
What's up there?
How mysterious.
This is PTSD.
Ah!
Oh man, the toilet's open.
Can we go in here?
Oh, we can.
I did see that the other door was open.
We'll check that out before we...
The colors are making me dizzy.
Ah!
It was a she ghost!
I still...
I started out that way.
Well, I didn't start out that way, but everybody, every
ghost has their sheet ghost phase.
It's just, you know.
Uh, rotate.
Oh.
Oh, zoo.
Oh, okay.
It looked like there's something on it, but it's just really
textured for some reason.
Oh.
Daddy?
Daddy, are you okay?
You hear that?
Oh, she's watching TV!
Hold on, I gotta go to the bathroom first.
Okay, never mind.
We can't, it won't even let me open it.
Okay.
Don't jump scare me!
Ah!
Oh, it's loud.
We turn away, we don't have to hear it.
It's a ghost off?
Is that my sister?
Because you're like really tall.
Maybe this is the dad.
Are we the dad?
Wait, I thought I was finding my sister.
Hello?
Don't jump scare me.
Yeah!
That works too.
Everything be flickering in here.
Stop!
What's this?
This wasn't here before.
I would have noticed it with the potato, I think.
You can zoom in.
Oh, cool.
Can't believe that guy was loitering in the house.
Trying to take my job for real.
Am I supposed to do something?
I can't even tell what that is.
It's so gritty.
What am I hearing?
Hello?
What is the sound?
The wardrobe?
Don't jump...
Oh.
Don't jump scare me!
Do I go in there?
No?
Oh,
she's gone.
my God.
Oh, my God.
Anything in here?
Little rubber...
Was the rubber duckie new?
I love you, Dad.
I love you dad.
I love you too, my daughter.
This way?
I love you dad.
Oh!
The doll is...
The doll and the ghost are...
Related.
I love you, dad.
I love you, too.
Why is this?
It was so like...
Do we go in this door now?
No.
Again?
Up there?
I can't go.
It's so like...
Oh my god, please.
Okay, we get it, we get it.
You love your dad.
Oh my god, we get it.
Where are you talking from?
Oh, I hear someone singing too.
Creepy.
Oh, shut up, please.
Oh my god, where are we?
Stop.
I love you, Dad.
Here?
Oh, I found it.
I love you, Dad.
Yeah.
Oh.
We meet again.
Uh.
Dad?
Dad, you're not going to leave me, right?
No!
Happened to me.
Dad!
Oh, we can finally go in here now.
And there's a bigger potato.
Well?
I'm going to...
Wait, I'm 8?
Oh my god!
There's handcuffs!
Yeah, it's freaky.
They left twice.
I know, right?
Oh, wow.
Um.
The lighting in this is something.
Do you think if I zoom in, something will happen?
I'm scared.
Okay, here I go.
Ah!
Okay.
They were more afraid of me.
Eight?
Was there a...
Was there something that I needed to check?
Oh wait Oh the Nine?
Is it going up?
Where's that a seven?
I can't tell it.
Wait.
Seven.
Six?
I was shopping for groceries When the FF7...
Oh.
FF7, Revelation was announced, my body's ready for boy rude.
Yeah!
I love it, Elena.
Five?
We're gonna get jump scared for real.
Four!
Three!
It's not dead!
Whatever!
I'm controlling my own jump scare.
Okay, nothing lunged at me, so that's good, I guess.
Oh.
Ah.
A baby.
Oh, baby.
Oh, baby, shut up.
Oh, the baby.
Shut up, baby.
I can't really tell the story at all so far.
Wait, is there...
Oh, I thought I saw another note.
Oh, the baby's gone.
The baby is now...
We're playing hide-and-seek, though, still, I think?
Story?
She's having a bad time.
You're fine.
Oh.
I like the rubber duckie.
I'm a big fan.
I'm a big fan of the duckie on the ground.
Oh.
Oh my gosh!
She's possessed!
Oh my god!
Do it again.
I dare you.
I dare you do it.
Do it again.
I'm scared something's gonna be behind me.
Yeah!
Oh the door!
Oh I forgot that we got the key to the door.
That was cool.
Do it again.
We're stomping.
We're like...
We're like stomping through here.
Been bonding for the past month.
How many of you able to catch your streams live again?
I missed you.
Liquidos!
Welcome back!
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
Investigate the... Oh, this was the sound.
Oh, the picture fell.
I'm recording the evidence?
Stop breaking glass.
What?
They think it's like Minecraft.
You just pick up some sand and you can make glass instantly.
But no!
This is... this is destroying my hard-earned money.
This place could use some work.
You know?
These walls are... I don't even know what...
What that is...
What causes that?
Is this even your house?
Oh true, what if we're like a ghost hunter or something?
Alright, let's go into the parents' room.
The ultimates.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
What is that?
What does that sound?
Oh!
I couldn't tell!
It was so dark!
What was I supposed to see?
We'll not open that just yet.
Let's see if there's anything else.
The bear?
Okay.
I'm scared to look out the way down!
Okay, we're fine.
The window.
Yeah, I guess they opened it.
Oh, nasty!
Oh,
I guess it says...
Wait.
I guess it says nothing.
Yeah.
Is that Papa in the...
In the bag, too?
He's happy.
She created her own Ducky Makuta.
At least he's happy, right?
You think the potato is possessed.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, my God.
Um...
The crawling in through the window sequence was so scary and
then she just poofed out of existence.
Can I leave?
Ah!
Oh my god.
Oh.
Uh.
Can I leave?
No.
Oh my god.
The flashing lights are killing me.
I can't see anything you guys.
I actually can't...
Wait.
What was that?
Oh, examine?
Oh, can someone...
Oh, thank goodness.
Um...
E.
Oh, thank goodness.
Alright.
Can we leave?
We can leave.
Thank goodness.
I turned the volume down just a little bit because it's so
loud.
What does it say?
Honey!
the candles for me.
Oh, a key.
E.
I don't like this part.
This is kind of spooky.
With the candles.
Oh, there's one.
So romantic.
On the bed?
So dangerous.
How romantic.
Oh, here's one too.
I almost missed it.
Okay, so something's wrong with mom.
If you guys could not tell.
If you guys couldn't tell, I think there's something wrong
with mom and her potato collection.
Maybe she ate...
Oh, again?
Again?
Okay.
Maybe it was some really bad potatoes, like...
Oh my god!
Oh god!
She didn't cook them, she ate them raw or something.
And caused some poisoning of the brain.
There's no candle in here?
Oh, yes there is.
It's so hard to see it.
The Phanab sound jump scare.
Oh, that's...
That probably scared me the most.
Oh, I got goosebumps from that one.
Did you see that?
Ooh.
I was wondering why the sheet didn't disappear.
We didn't give it enough time.
We didn't give it enough time to zip out of existence.
Alright.
Surely they wouldn't have the the sheet ghost come back
again some rooms have two so uh there might be a second one
in here can't be so sure they just put candles on the beds
and couches so oh yes okay cool i got mom got really into
yoga hope you're doing wonderfully thank you
I feel like that's all of them, no?
Wait, oh, that's just a...
Yeah, it doesn't work anymore.
I love that they made it even more difficult to see in the
game.
The game was hard to see, and then they made it even more.
Light the candles for me.
I did!
Is it not all of them?
Did I miss one?
Hmm.
Damn.
There was two in here.
These cheap ass jump scares are gonna...
Oh, there's one here.
These cheap ass jump scares, I swear.
Oh, uh...
Okay.
Maybe that's all of them then.
That one got me.
Wait.
There was one down here.
It's gone now.
Oh.
The house has changed.
Bumper.
Cheap but effective.
I know.
What's going to come at us?
What is this?
September 23rd.
Oh, that was two days ago.
Except because it's September 25th.
Mommy and Daddy.
Well, Mommy said Daddy went on a trip.
But he didn't say goodbye.
He always says goodbye.
I think maybe he forgot something here.
His shoes are still in the hallway.
Dun, dun.
It's kind of rare to have, like, a killer mom in these games
rather than, like, a dad that kills everybody.
You know what I mean?
I'm gonna guess I was gonna say all of these don't open but
oh there's something in here excuse me
should be running should be running and she'd be running
should be running and she'd be running okay bye
mommy drank that stinky stuff again she said it helps her
forget things but then she got mad at me i didn't say
anything bad i promise she yelled so loud my ears hurt she
hit me i don't know why she's mad maybe i make her think of
daddy i want her to like me again oh okay please don't jump
scare me
is that door gonna slam oh oh oh oh Ma'am?
Ma'am?
I'm gonna zoom in.
Ah!
Okay.
I'm gonna open the door.
Oh, never mind.
How polite!
Uh...
Okay, wait.
This one.
Mommy cries a lot in the kitchen now.
She doesn't cook pancakes anymore.
She just stares at the window.
I asked if Daddy called and she got mad.
She said I shouldn't talk about him.
But I miss him.
Aww.
What about, this is, I guess...
Which sister is writing this?
No more pancakes!
Literally my biggest fear.
That's no more pancakes.
Ugh.
So many notes.
I found one of dad's shirts.
It smells bad and...
Wait.
And needs washing.
Mom told me not to go up to the attic anymore.
Sometimes I hear her talking upstairs.
Sometimes I hear someone else too.
Maybe dad's back.
Don't jump scare me.
Okay.
a chair.
Don't jump scare me.
Eep, eep, eep, eep.
Oh, no.
It's all of them.
All the sheet ghosts.
They're having a party without us.
What was it?
The heck was that... Ew, what was that noise?
A cold Mommy told me daddy is in a better place I asked
where that is And she smiled really wide She said if I'm
good maybe I can go there too I told her I'll be good I
promise The ghosts Oh no ghost cult We're getting the whole
story all at once Please tell me the potatoes are safe
That's what they're doing!
They're burning all the crops!
They're burning everything!
Hold on a second.
I'm gonna... wait.
Wait.
One second.
I'm gonna try and fix something on here.
Real quick.
There we go.
Canadian jump scare!
Oh my gosh, you are the patriotic Canadian.
Thank you for the super time!
okay mommy was clearing the floor the red stuff wouldn't
come off she told me it was paint she said daddy made her do
it daddy made her do
it mommy said if I miss daddy so much she'll take me to
where he is she's smiling again she said it won't hurt for
long I'm scared but maybe daddy will be waiting for me good
night diary I think mommy's coming oh terrifying what does
say i did i didn't want to do this she shouldn't have seen
oh my god oh my god mom please don't jump scare me you
shouldn't have seen sometimes for these like types of games
i wish they wouldn't like use a font you know what i mean
like if you have to use your own handwriting and like just
slap it on as a png like just do that instead it's so much
scarier just draw it
don't jump scare me okay don't jump scare me oh oh no the
ritual i tried to bring her back wait is the devil is the
the evil ghost My sister?
Trees.
Trees and trees and trees.
Don't jump scare me.
Don't jump scare me!
Goat?
Oh my god!
Please the ritual!
Don't jump scare me.
I'm being told to complete the ritual, you guys.
For those who don't understand that reference, I once had a
dream.
I had a dream that I was just being a silly goose, but I was
plagued by these three goats that would be like, Minto, you
must complete the ritual.
You must do the things for the ritual.
okay and so I would be like okay whatever and then I would
just like go about and do whatever and then they would come
back to me and they'd be like no no Victor you must complete
my ritual you must complete the ritual they were getting so
mad at me.
What ritual was it?
I have no idea.
Ducky, ducky.
Uh-oh.
Oh.
Bathroom?
Bathtub?
We got something here.
Looking for your sister?
Yeah?
Oh.
At least these are easy to find.
She misses you too!
So I think we are the older sister.
Stop being distracted by cute idols.
Complete the ritual!
It was a while ago, so I don't quite remember the, uh...
The dream, exactly.
But it was like on an old stream, I talked about it.
Uh, she...
She misses you too.
Is there another note somewhere?
Oh, here we go.
Did you look behind the curtain?
No.
Is it this one?
This curtain?
I'm scared.
Don't jump scare me.
Ah!
Mom, stop backseating our hide and seek game.
My goodness.
oh sorry that's not meek that wasn't meek
mom needs a shirt on and under the bed thanks mom oh how
could i forget Where's the next one?
Oh.
She's with daddy now.
I'm done.
What are we saying?
Congrats about.
Today has probably been one of the better ones of the past
year.
Has been unemployed for a bit.
But finally got a new job in a field I've always been trying
for.
Oh my gosh.
Techno-Afro.
Congratulations.
She's with daddy now, you guys.
Potato.
Want mommy to take you, too?
What was that?
She coming?
Can we hide?
Oh, wait.
Oh, what's...
Oh, this opened.
Oh.
Mommy's here!
Hide!
Don't let her see you!
Please hide!
Okay, I'm getting under the bed.
Oh, I'm getting under the bed!
Hide!
I am?
Oh, it says hide, hide, hide, hide, hide.
I thought that she was... I thought she was coming in.
I thought the door was opening.
I can't see anything.
Am I supposed to see mommy?
Well, luckily we were smart enough to put out the candle,
right?
just kidding I forgot Mammy has superpowers Oh
Oh my god I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm
running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running,
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm
I'm running,
running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running,
I'm running in slow motion Hopefully I'm faster than her Oh
my god the blinking lights are kind of terrible Oh, I'm
hiding, I'm hiding, I'm hiding?
How would she know?
How would she know that I'm in the cabinet at the end of the
hallway that has no exit?
How would she know?
Is the bitrate okay?
Uh...
Uh, can we stop that?
Can we stop that?
My eyes.
Can we stop this?
No.
It's toast.
Has it been okay at all throughout this entire game?
Is it in here?
We have a date change to the 12th.
Maybe a TV.
What's that sound?
Hello?
Can I leave?
can I leave where's the sound coming from am I crazy I
thought I was
not sure what they want me to do there's like arguing but
you think they're arguing upstairs maybe oh
oh oh Wait, it's a cutscene?
Uh oh.
Oh no, we're gonna get go!
Oh gosh.
Oh, I'm in the void!
Yeah, they're not arguing anymore.
Tape A complete.
Or playback complete.
Remaining tapes 1.
There's a second ending?
I wonder...
Yippee!
Wait, what could the second ending be, though?
I think I'm good, though.
I think I'm good.
We were too well hidden, you guys.
We were just...
I don't know.
Hold on.
Where does it continue us at?
If I have to play the entire game again, then That would be
Oh, I wonder if you get Got by the mom instead if it's
something different Hold on, we could do this Real fast,
right?
Oh And two Uh, where was three again?
Oh, in here?
Hold on.
My curiosity.
Looking for your sister?
Is she...
Where's the next one?
Wait, I thought it was in the chair.
Oh, no.
We already did this looking.
Oh, wait.
Where was it?
What did this one say?
Oh, behind the curtain!
Ah!
Yes!
Under the bed?
How could I forget?
She's with daddy now.
Oh, not yet.
There we go.
She's with daddy now.
Do you want to join her?
And then this opens.
And then she's like, Mommy, is she coming?
You have to hide.
And we don't hide.
Oh, there are little pieces of paper that say hide.
Okay, I'm brave.
We face her.
I'm scared.
Oh, she blew out my candle.
Why didn't I just, yeah, whack her in the face?
Oh my god!
I'm a police officer!
Wee-woo!
Oh!
I'm a police officer Something definitely happened In this
household I can I can sense it With my With my Definitely Oh
The power set Okay Definitely in there Oh that's dark too
How are the lights With that How are they showing up and
this how are there's like a rave in the house like the how
are the lights showing up on the wall here we can finally go
upstairs though uh do i have a flashlight i'm a police
office thank you okay
she blows out the candle and jump scares you got it oh my
god what's around there's a goat there's a goat in the attic
there's a goat in the attic probably
what was that oh my god how are the police lights happening
here too mom put on a rave before killing everybody how are
the police oh don't look you too
oh no our potatoes Who gets the fancy ones?
Clearly there's a favorite.
Oh, mom is floating.
There's not even a rope.
She's just hanging out.
Oh, wait, what's happening?
Oh, geez.
Oh, oh, oh.
Wait, but who's, I don't get, oh, God.
Okay, I can't, I can barely move.
Oh my god, everything's rumbling.
Get out of the house!
It's coming down!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, it's so...
Oh!
Stop!
Thank you.
Tape B, stop.
We did it.
All tapes viewed.
No additional tapes found.
Yay!
We beat the game!
Well, wow, oh my goodness gracious.
Oh, my goodness gracious.
Well, since I don't have to, well, I'll just keep being
cheapy, it's fine.
We have one more game that we can do.
It's about another hour-long one, so...
That wasn't the greatest game.
That's okay.
Sometimes it's really fun to play.
silly horror games I enjoy those too I quite enjoy this
genre as well I almost want to leave a review on that game
for the revenge of my eyes that was the epitome of horror
I enjoy yeah horror slop I enjoy it the next one is probably
like that too today is more silly horror game to admit Maybe
this one's called the ramen shop, but there's like this
genre of like horror games that I've noticed recently where
one second I'm opening it up where um
they they are I don't think they're made by Japanese people
like this one is definitely like a Chilla's art clone.
Dream Chasers!
Thank you so much for the gifted.
Thank you.
Let's see.
The ramen shop.
There we go.
Like it's in the Chilla's font, or not like font, but format
and everything.
It's so funny.
But this one is all about ramen, baby.
Which I kind of, maybe I'll get that after this.
I don't know.
Start game.
I guess some people just like Japan.
Day what?
Oh, yeah.
I'm, I'm, look at this.
Oh, wow.
Where?
Oh, here.
Hey, kid.
It's Mr. Sato.
PT is quite silent since this came out PT saw hidden too
well and was just like or too well hidden and was like man
we don't even need to come back Mr. Sato we have souls like
so why not chill is like so true I've added the basic stuff
for you to start working if you get confused at any time I
made a board for you to follow on how to make the perfect
ramen.
Also, make sure to check the toppings board.
It will list on how much each toppings is needed for one
bowl.
Anyway, good luck, kiddo.
Fill the bowl with broth.
Open chop.
Open the blinds and start getting... Wow, customers!
Cook the noodles until soft.
Place the noodles in the bowl.
Add the correct portions of toppings.
Put the lid.
Serve it to the customer.
Portions.
Chashu 2.
Green onions 1.
Boiled eggs 2.
This is going to make me hungry.
New Uma JP scenario is going to be about Robin.
Wait, I'm going to turn up the sensitivity a little bit.
Wait.
Maybe I meant down.
That's better, I think.
So we got some chicken ramen.
We got some spicy ramen.
Yes.
Our trash bin.
This is our strainer.
We got our broths.
And we've got our chashu.
Raw noodles.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Yes.
Two eggs is generous, right?
Alright, let's open up shop, baby.
Somebody come to my... Where?
Are we in like an alleyway?
Hey, you're the new employee, right?
Yeah, I am.
What can I get you today?
Let me get one chicken ramen with chasu and green onions.
Okay!
Chicken ramen, chasu.
Okay.
Where's a bowl?
Oh, here's a bowl.
Ew.
Ramen?
Wait, what do I...
Nice.
Can I put this away?
Oh, there we go.
It's two chashu, right?
The bowl holder.
No, it says bowl lid.
And then one green onion, right?
And then, oh, there's a drop button.
There you go!
Thanks.
As I say, in deep Japan.
Arigato.
Ramen cellar, I require your spiciest ramen.
You cannot handle my spiciest ramen.
But ramen cellar...
But ramen cellar, I require your spiciest ramen for I must
go to work and I need the sustenance.
How dare!
You think that you can handle it.
Go on, Salary Man.
Do not ever try to have this ramen again unless you have
gained the knowledge.
I have fought many battles to be here, Ramen Seller.
Please, may I just have a little taste of the broth?
I promise I can handle it.
I know you.
I know you salary man.
You think you can handle this, but your mouth is merely like
a baby's.
And I will not be held responsible for your IBS.
Ramanseller.
I have been on medication for many, many months to handle my
IBS.
The incident was not my fault.
I have learned my lesson and now I am ready to partake in
the spiciest of your romans very well salaryman but i will
not be purchasing your next pair of pants thank you
ramazeller
that's some spicy
That's some spicy ramen!
A ramen seller!
Are you sure this is allowed to have on the market?
I warned you.
I warned you, celery man.
This is the consequences of your actions.
This is what happens when you get too cocky.
You're welcome.
Good luck with the new job.
Thank you.
I served my first customer.
Better than any movies.
Oh.
it was only 500 yen she left me like 2000 hello hey there
nice to see some new faces did his pants survive what do you
think never let never be said that mint half does a bit
that's her lord luna welcome to membership thank you tip for
the story she was just standing there like Like, can I get
some chopsticks or...
I'm starving.
Let me get two chicken romans!
All right, hungry boy.
Yes.
Two chicken romans.
One, two...
Oh, I forgot the ramen.
Cook noodle.
And a lid.
And one more.
Oops.
Boop.
I like the sound effects in this game.
they're quite satisfying it's very quiet though right like
it kind of feels oh no oh no wait I thought it was always
the chasu but sometimes it's wait I got the entire thing
wrong
why didn't you say that sometimes that you wanted eggs also
the total would not be 500 yen it would be 1,000.
Oh, no!
Two chicken ramen, please.
That's all he said.
I have to throw everything away.
Wait.
I hope these people don't have...
Wait, limit.
Wait, sir.
I wonder.
Would he still eat it?
Oh.
No!
He doesn't even reprimand me!
Oh my gosh, I have to make it all again.
I'm getting it fired for sure.
Okay, wait.
One was chashu and boiled eggs.
That is like...
It was two chashu, two boiled eggs, right?
Yeah.
Oh wait, did I put noodle in there?
There we go.
Okay, this is done.
And then the next one.
The ambience, it's like way too quiet, no?
Like it's so quiet.
Okay, it was a Chasu boiled eggs and then boiled eggs and
green onion.
Just make it super spicy.
Okay.
Boiled egg.
One, two, lid, and we're good.
Thanks.
Also, can you guys hear it at all?
You're kind of cute!
Any chance I could get your number?
No.
Screw you!
I turned up the ambience just a little bit.
At least he paid.
I hear somebody.
Oh, she's so cool wearing her sunglasses at night.
Let me get one spicy ramen.
Salary man.
And do it fast.
That's somewhere to be.
Okay, come and read the...
Boiled eggs at...
Okay, spicy, but with the boiled eggs.
Boiled eggs and green onion.
One.
And a strainer.
Cook noodle, cook noodle.
We got that real fast for you, ma'am.
Oh.
You took that long just to make a simple ramen?
I did it so fast!
Now I'm gonna miss my meeting, thanks to you.
Maybe you shouldn't have stopped for food!
Oh, she did pay.
Okay.
Look, we've made 2,000 yen so far.
I hear somebody?
Oh, this lady is so nice.
Hi there, sweetie.
Looks like you're new here.
It's a good thing that Mr. Sato hired you.
He's getting sick a lot recently.
Anyway, please get me one chicken and one spicy ramen.
You've got it, ma'am.
Let's cook some...
Oh.
No, oops.
Oh, that's fine, probably.
I was going to make some more noodles.
Okay.
one normal one spicy okay boiled eggs on the chicken and
everything on the spicy boiled eggs on the chicken and green
onion this is relaxing so far this is pretty nice this is
pretty nice so far yeah the works wait I think I forgot the
noodles can I take off the in.
Oops.
I forgot the noodles, you guys.
It was boiled it.
This is fine.
This is...
Of course, who would have went ramen without the men, right?
Okay, we can use that chashu.
She'll never know.
She'll never know what's been touched a million times.
Like, this is a proper ramen, I'd say.
Giving the low-carb option.
We offer noodles, and we also offer soup.
These look delicious.
Thanks!
I'll be sure to come here again.
Thank you so much, Madame.
Cook noodle, cook noodle.
This one has been cooked for a while.
Oh, I hear somebody hello hey what's up kid i just finished
a 12-hour shift sitting in a computer all day is really
killing me anyway give me one chicken ramen with all of the
toppings yeah see that's what you gotta say you can't just i
don't know how they expect me to know you know what i mean
how am i supposed to know that they want everything if they
don't say it i thought i saw something him that was kind of
creepy i don't think i did though jeshu jeshu
the horror part is working a customer service job i feel
that too sometimes i feel like that's what these games are
right they'll be like a retail simulator that are have
horror aspects and i'm like i think working the job is the
scariest part thank you very much also do you sell any
drinks here i'm thirsty for some cold tea oh sorry we don't
sell any drinks yet we are we are so there's like uh they
call them like there's like certain stores in japan that's
that specialize in a certain thing it'll be like curry pan
senmon and like like the senmon is like they're the
How do you say it?
Like, their specialty.
And so, you'll find stores that are like, this place is
curry pine specialty.
I've never actually, like, been to one, I think.
So I don't know if, like, that's truly all they sell.
Because I'm also, like, it must be really dang good, you
know, to be able to stay in business while only selling.
one thing.
I went to one that was just egg tarts.
What?
That's crazy!
You should really add some.
I would go here every day if you sell drinks.
Okay.
Yes, sir.
I'm telling my boss right now.
Oh, it's time to close the shop.
Mop the floor.
The dang.
That is, that is the Chillas Art convenience store.
jump scare
that was it I'm calling the police oh I'm sorry I didn't
mean to scare you calm down I'm Sato's brother who?
I'm Sato's brother my brother is the man who hired you he
didn't tell me you were coming in or you were coming here I
just came to check on you well you gave me a heart attack
I'm really sorry again it's not fine but I'm saying it is
you should go home and rest I'll close up shop Mr. Sato told
me to clean up first before going home.
Haha, it's fine.
He won't know.
Do ghosts get scared of other ghosts?
Sometimes.
Besides, I have a couple of things to do here myself.
Oh, okay, thanks.
The exit just threw the back door.
But my duty is to mop the shop.
If I come back and this spot is still here, Mr. Sato, Sato's
brother I'm going to have really really bad words to say
okay this place better be spotless I was I was prepared
fully prepared for my duties the mop is in the closet what
kind of bad words things like poopy head and doo-doo for
brains all right mr.
Sato hey again kid I have brought some new toppings for the
romans make sure to check the toppings board also there's a
refrigerator stock with green tea I won't be doing more
delivery since my condition condition is getting worse it's
fine I have someone to bring new items each day anyway have
fun at work.
Oh, wait.
This is a new stain.
Probably from the fridge.
Oh, yeah.
We got some some green tea, baby.
Oh.
Who want that?
Who wants the green tea?
Wait, what new toppings do we have?
Nori!
We got the seaweed, baby.
Oh, too Nori.
Okay.
Yeah, we got the Itoan knockoff.
Hi, sweetie.
I told you I would come here again.
I see you've added nori to the menu.
Let me get one spicy ramen, please.
Dang, grandma's tough.
Nori and boiled eggs.
So is the horror that...
The brother?
Two nori.
Two boiled eggs.
Oh, I didn't make any noodles.
I keep finding myself hummingburn-on.
Thank you for making such a pop.
Thank you for listening!
The horror is the pay.
Thank you so much, dear.
You're welcome.
Was that the wrong...
Your?
Guys, here is your lesson.
Okay.
Check this out.
Here, hold on.
This is how I always remember.
Okay.
Your...
What's the last one?
Wait.
wait York York
okay your this one in the middle is you are right you are
and then this one is your thang so the first thing the first
one is to is to have like a possession of a thing like your
your thing the second thing is you are that's what the
little apostrophe is for it's it's it's it's making it's
getting rid of the a but it's you are so you're going to the
place you are going to the place and then york the place new
york
so you are your uh your your your is going to york you're
going to york you're your
your your is going to york you are going to york
francis york morgan but please call me york that is your
your lesson it's a pos it's your possession of the lesson
your lesson you can think of it as this your is is your
possession and then you are getting possessed by minto you
are will this be on the test absolutely and then york is the
place the time the time is your the time and 4d equals the
time forward and backward
plus smell because smello vision smello vision is new age uh
40 so you have 40 of the past backward and then you have 40
of the future which is smell of vision
i see i'm teaching i'm teaching what does 40 mean
40 oh like 40 versus 4d 40 is in demand and everyone wants a
4d 40 woman who will pamper and take care of them.
Is there a song that'll help me remember all this?
I'll sing it right now.
Your is your possession.
Your is you.
Don't forget the little apostrophe.
It decapitates the A, but that's okay because it makes it
short and york is the place, the place where you're getting
possessed by minto.
And what time is that?
It's the york and the four and the d.
We're going forward and backward in time, but don't forget
the smell.
Smell of vision is the future and what?
is the difference between 40 and 40.
Well, everybody wants a 40-year-old woman in their lives
that is pampering them and taking care of them and making
them feel special and patting their head and making them
feel awesome.
Yor, yor is going to York.
Yor, going to York.
Your yore is going to york and you're going to york and when
you get there you'll fin and she will pamper you as long as
you use proper grammar and don't forget the differences
between your yore york, your 40th smell of a shed.
All right, clash.
That was something.
Oh, grandma.
I hope you know the difference between two for yours now.
Grandma, I hope you learned your lesson.
I just wanted some ramen.
Well, maybe!
Maybe you should have used proper grammar!
I would understand her!
Everyone wants a stinky older woman to pamper them.
Is this about Matara?
This is never about Matara.
Her ego is too large.
We can't continue...
feeding her into her ego.
Meanwhile, the lady ignores her confusion and very patiently
awaits her robin.
My shirt says 35 plus, which includes 40 plus.
Oh, yeah.
Good job, Seymour.
You're all... You are...
You...
Apostrophe R-E.
You're already on the right track.
How's it working here?
It's alright.
At least I can pay the bills.
Alright, just make sure to lock the shop at night.
That was so educational.
You learn a lot at Minto Channel.
Minto Phantom Channel.
But Zach, what about the second York?
Make sure to lock the shop up at night.
There has been a robbery a couple days ago, and they still
haven't found the ones who did it.
Thanks for letting me know.
Thanks, Grandma.
My total cash.
Gosh, slow night tonight.
Cook noodle and strainer.
Hey!
Hello.
Hey girl.
Nice shop you got going here.
Why on earth is such talent stuck in a ramen shop?
It's a ramen shop and also...
Edgima cage.
Edgima.
Entertainment game.
Thanks, what can I get you?
I'm not really into spicy food.
Okay, well we have chicken broth.
Do you have any other broth besides chicken?
No.
Okay then, just give me one chicken ramen.
Okay, anything else?
One green tea please.
Oh, I thought our fridge was empty for a second.
Oops.
Place it, place it.
Place it?
Place it!
A guy?
Something that doesn't mean that so much it hurts.
Why are you nesting glitch case?
Did your other account get banned or something?
Are you being shadow banned at the moment?
We need boiled eggs and nori.
It's acting up!
Oh no!
Well...
I'm glad you have at least a second account.
Wait.
Let me place the tea?
Why wouldn't it let me?
Uh-oh.
Is the game glitched?
Oh!
There we go.
Mmm, smells tasty, but you should really...
add more broth flavors.
It would bring a lot more customers for sure.
Thank you for your opinion.
Someone's gonna get the floor.
Floor tea.
Okay, now that...
4D, 4D, and floor tea.
Now we need to go through the...
Hello?
Hey there, nice to see you again.
Is this the guy that asked me for my number?
Damn it all comes full search.
One more time!
Yours is your possession!
Give me one chicken ramen please.
You want the chasu and the nori and the green onion.
Chasu?
And the nori.
And the green onion.
Onion.
Oh, make your first 5,000 yen.
Yikes.
How many can we stack?
Hello?
Are you impressed?
One chicken ramen, one green tea.
And make it quick.
I have investors waiting for you.
to be at the office.
It looks like it's like 11 p.m.
Howl.
Chasunori chicken broth.
We gotta make some more noodles.
Chasun.
Nori.
There you go, sir.
This looks fine.
Thanks, I guess.
Drop it on the floor.
I should have.
Next time you're getting a floor ramen.
No, no.
No!
I can't make it!
Oh!
Where's the light switch?
Ah!
Thank you, ghost.
Eee!
Oh, the spooky's happening!
The spooky isn't coming up!
Are you real or are you ghost?
Oh, is this lady again?
One chicken ramen, one spicy ramen, and a green tea.
Chicken, spicy...
This place is so dark and didn't think there was any
noticeable difference.
Thanks for your lesson.
Unfortunately, they're taken away by a high school diploma
because of your lesson.
I think maybe your lessons are too hard for me.
You're the best.
Red!
Spicy chicken.
Chicken is...
Chashu boiled eggs.
Mmm, some nice protein.
Hardy, hardy, hardy, hardy male.
You like that lady?
Hardy, hardy, hard, hard, hardy meal.
Hardy, hardy, hard!
Boiled eggs in the room.
Sorry.
Boiled eggs!
Endori.
Wait, did I give her...
I gave her noodles, right?
Dang it!
Dang
it!
Oops, I always forget the noodles.
What was it?
Too... too boiled egg.
Hardy, hardy.
It can only be stupid if I'm also doing my job correctly.
Yeah, this is good enough.
Wasting so much food.
I'm the worst for real.
Why am I being haunted, huh?
What have I done?
Is it because I'm not cool enough?
Hold on, watch this.
No!
Hagen, give me one chicken ramen, please.
Chasu, green onion, nori.
Chasu, green onion.
I need the instructions to also say noodles.
Or else I forget!
There you go.
Thanks, see you around!
No, thank you, my loyal customer.
The other ghosts are jealous.
Hello, one second.
Oh!
Yes?
Hey again, kiddo.
I see you've got some drinks now.
Oh, we got it recently.
Haunted by bowls of wasted ramen past.
Yeah, the ghost is mad at me, bro.
What if they get more mad the more you mess up?
Let me get one chicken ramen with a green tea.
Chicken ramen.
Chasu boiled eggs, green onion.
Oh, I'm going to need to make some more.
Oops.
Uh, what was it?
Sorry, Mr. I forgot.
Chasu boiled eggs.
Green onion.
Chashul.
Boiled eggs.
Your meal is served.
Thanks, kid.
You're welcome.
Wait, did he take a drink?
Oh, I guess he did.
Sending spicy nudes alive.
Oh, we're done.
I'm turning down the sound in case we get jump scared again.
Okay.
No guy today, thank goodness.
I'm mopping.
Now we just have to worry about a ghost, I guess.
Really cool.
We're just leaving everything on?
Okay.
Oh.
Did I get it?
Oh, exit.
Okay.
See ya.
You undercooked the noodles and the ghost of Gordon Ramsay
pops up and calls you a donkey.
No, day three!
Do you think it gets scary at five nights?
Oh, why are the lights off?
How do I turn them on?
How do I turn the lights on?
Oh, what?
Put it in the trash?
Make some noodles?
Oh, we can't open this door?
What is this thing?
Is this a voodoo doll?
I think so.
Oh my god!
It is!
What is this?
This looks really creepy.
I should probably inform Mr. Sato about this.
Mr. Sato, did you pay the power bill?
Hey.
Is this a Mika?
Yes it is.
Is this Minto?
I'm Kenji.
I'm the guy Mr. Sato hired to deliver the ingredients to
you, remember?
I mean, it was never told a name, but you.
Anyway, I've delivered multiple new toppings to you.
Make sure to take a look at the toppings board.
Um, ask about the doll and the candles.
A doll?
Sounds like a prank by some kids.
Oh, this looks really bad.
These kids watch too many horror movies.
And they're really creative about pranking people.
Just throw the doll and candles in the bin.
Anyway, I've really got to go do some deliveries.
You'll be fine, good luck.
How do I turn the lights on?
I feel like I'm gonna get jump-scared by something.
Stop doing rituals at my store.
You're making it haunted.
Gosh, dang it.
You guys are making my place haunted with your stupid
rituals.
It's already haunted because you work there.
Yeah, but like in the game, Mika is not a ghost.
I think.
Unless...
Hello.
Hey there.
Let me get one chicken ramen and one tea please.
Also, I'm currently working down the street, so I'll
probably come here again for some drinks.
Green tea.
Oh, we got beer!
It's beer o'clock, buddy!
What are you doing?
Oh, we have...
Naruto Maki!
How many... I imagine maybe two?
Yeah.
It's so dark.
Can I turn up the brightness?
No.
What did it?
Oh, and we also got pork broth!
Pork broth, chicken broth.
Chashu green onion, Naruto maki.
Nice.
Delicious.
Now, this is a hearty mayo.
Hearty, heart, heart, heart.
Ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, for you.
Thanks.
I'll see you soon.
Datte bayou, Mr. Officer.
Have you ever been to one of those places that, like, sings
when you order?
I think Coldstone used to do that.
You would, like, tip them and they would sing.
Coldstone, the ice cream place?
Oh, my goodness.
You scared the heck out of me.
Hello, Mr. Broad shoulders.
I just got my first job at the accounting firm downtown.
Thanks, I'm really excited about this job.
The pay is also really good there.
Anyway, let me get one pork ramen, please.
I tried so hard to make sure, like, didn't see me tip.
Pork broth.
Nori chashio green onion.
If anything, I'm enjoying the...
The monotony of just being able to have this job.
Nori Chashu green onion.
I love green onion in my ramen.
Thanks.
By the way, nice shop you got here.
Do you own it or are you just an employee?
I'm just an employee.
Ah, got it.
Just keep working and it will probably be yours soon.
Oh.
What is that supposed to mean?
Why would it end up being mine?
Is that how it works?
What?
Why would you say that?
You just think that...
Yeah, ominous, for real.
Hey there, let me get one beer, please.
Beer o'clock!
Thanks, by the way, I heard the owner of this place has
gotten sick.
Yeah, that's what I heard.
Yeah, he's gonna assassinate your boss.
He's a good friend of mine.
Do you know I got him sick?
I'm not sure.
Okay, I won't waste any more of your time, but if you happen
to know, please let me know.
Yes, sir.
How much is the beer?
500 yen.
Wow.
it's the same price as the green tea i think i hear a cat
howling outside hold on i'm gonna check real quick one
second lady who's always in a rush green onion or grognon
for short no no grognon this sounds like groin to me
so i there's there's been a new development there's been
these cats these like they're not strays one of them is
definitely not a stray i'm not sure about the other one but
cat this new cat has come along and now howls every time he
sees the other girl cat and is driving me insane there's
like a girl cat and then there's this new other cat that is
always like wow wow wow every time he sees the lady cat he
yearns for her.
He's a real yearner.
Just one spicy ramen.
You could say please.
This is why I had kept you waiting lady.
This is why I kept you late.
Wait, waiting.
I kept you lady.
I could, it's, his meow is so loud.
Naruto maki, boiled eggs, chasu.
Chasu, chasu, chasu, chasu, chasu, boiled eggs.
Oh, it's just the same thing.
The Naruto Tomaki is new, though.
There you go, lady.
Thanks.
You're welcome.
She used to wrong your again!
Cat calls her for real.
You should feel lucky working in a place like this.
The nine-to-five working life is tiring.
So is dealing with customers like you.
It's not a competition, lady.
Jobs are...
Tiring, okay?
Jeez.
I get it, though.
I know her struggles.
Give me one pork ramen and one beer, please.
Yes, sir.
Coming right up.
Pork.
John pork.
Naruto Makinori.
Oops.
I didn't spill it.
You saw nothing.
Kept you lady, huh?
Are you ready?
I'm a lady.
Kept you lady.
No way.
Green onion or the donkey.
And green onion.
There you go, sir.
Oops.
Thanks.
Also, I wanted to say sorry about the other day.
I was really stressed out and I lashed out on you.
It's fine, sir.
Thank you.
Anyway, here's a little tip for you.
500 yen!
Thank you, sir.
Wow!
In three days we've made $100.
I don't think our business is booming, but we're doing our
best.
Hello.
Hey there, do you have any hot sauce here?
We only have spicy ramen.
I was watching this streamer, and he said mixing hot sauce
in your ramen will make it taste good.
Let's just try our spicy ramen instead.
Anyway, let me give one chicken ramen.
And one spicy ramen.
But only the broth.
Nothing else.
I'm good at that.
You're gonna pay for the whole thing, though, right?
Alright, chicken.
Chicken.
And it's...
Chashu, boiled eggs, nori, green onion.
Okay.
To be fair, our location is facing a murder alley.
That's so true.
My 18-year-old cat randomly went into heat for the first
time.
We had a boy cat at our window 24-7 until her medication
worked.
Then she attacked him.
Chashu.
Cats are so fine.
He ain't boiled egg.
Nori.
Ah, this is a really full Roman.
And a green onion.
Oh, it looks so good.
Oh, I'm jealous.
This looks yummy.
Thanks.
No worries.
Okay.
cats are strange i i uh actually the the girl cat outside
has like started following me back to my mid cafe and trying
to get inside i think she's trying to attack pies hello hey
gang girl i see you have a new bra flavor one pork ramen for
me please oh yeah i did it i did it just for you
Or...
Nori boiled eggs, Naruto maki.
Nori...
Boiled eggs.
Naruto maki.
Boom, bada bang, bada bang, bing, bong, bong, bong.
There you go.
Thank you!
Here's a tip for adding the new broth.
Wow!
I'm getting all sorts of tips today.
Women can't tell when someone is flirting either.
Let's go.
I'd like pork broth, please.
Are you coming on to me?
She just said it so nicely.
Another beer?
Hey again.
One beer, please.
You're my best customer.
Thanks.
This would hydrate me up for sure.
I don't know about that.
But okay.
Close the shop.
Okay, awfully normal day today.
So far, so good, maybe?
I'm not gonna get jump scared again, am I?
I leave with the mop?
Day four.
It is quiet.
All right.
Oh, we got mushrooms and corn.
Oh my gosh, corn is my favorite in everything.
Hey again.
I had delivered two new toppings.
Make sure to check them out.
The toppings board.
This will be the last delivery for a while.
I just recently had an accident on the road.
Are you all right?
Yeah, I'm all right.
It's just the doctor said to take it easy for now.
Corn?
Butter?
It's so good.
It's so good, I'm so hungry.
Anyway, I won't bother you with the details.
See you soon, Mika.
Bye-bye.
Whoa, corn and mushroom.
Mushroom was two, alright?
Yes.
Can we, like, start cleaning already?
No.
Dang, I was gonna be an early productive employee.
Oh, wait.
I didn't make any.
One second, one second.
Can please?
Yes?
Hey, we're having a party in my house.
Do you want to maybe join us?
I have...
I'm at work.
No worries.
Just give me one spicy ramen and four beers.
Okay.
Really is a party, huh?
Oh, no.
No!
This guy's the only one getting ramen, though.
Beer, beer, beer, beer.
spicy broth.
With mushroom, chashu, green onion.
Mushroom, chashu.
I'm glad I have the longest arms ever and green onion.
There you go, sir.
Thanks.
Again, the party is down the street if you change your mind.
I can barely see, actually.
I think I need to go to the doctor because I can't see
anything.
No.
Yes.
One second, kid.
Yeah.
Hey, big sis.
My grandma said she always buys ramen from the shop.
Can I have one chicken ramen, please?
Good manners, kid.
Maybe you need glasses.
I think I need a flashlight.
I...
Chashu Nori boiled eggs.
Chashu...
Chashu and Nori...
And Nori and boiled eggs.
Two of each.
You're gonna get two of each and a beer.
Never mind.
Don't... never mind.
You're a kid.
Humber's thought... the hundred percent thought that kid was
gonna ask for beer.
He's really impressed by my beer towel.
Thanks, kid.
Yes.
Hey there.
Do you have any chicken or other meat toppings?
We only have pork meat.
I see.
Just one chicken ramen and one pork ramen, then.
Okay.
Chicken.
Chicken is Chasu boiled eggs corn.
Chasu boiled eggs.
Oh, this sounds so good.
Guys, I'm hungry.
I'm hungry.
There's the chicken.
And pork is Chasu mushroom boiled eggs.
Chasu.
Mushroom.
Boiled eggs.
Toot, toot, toot, toot, toot, toot, toot, toot, toot, toot,
toot, toot, toot.
You have extra food in the trash?
No!
I take out the trash every night so that the rats don't get
in.
Thanks a lot.
My bad for the huge order.
I just, I need to consume a lot of food.
For my muscles.
Nobody asked.
Jim bros, man.
They just, they just tell you everything that you don't care
about.
Sorry, I'm just stretching on the job.
Hello?
Is anyone there?
Yes, sir.
What can I get you?
Hello there, Miss.
What kind of drinks do you have?
We have beer and green tea available.
Let me get two beers then.
No, my tower!
Thanks, Miss.
up I'm trying to build my tower
hello is anyone there oh creepy wait I'm saying that please
stop with these pranks it's not funny I'm fighting back yeah
is there gonna be a ghost behind me I just won't turn
around.
Grandma!
Hey again, honey.
My grandchild forgot to buy himself a drink.
The beer.
No worries.
One green tea, please.
Did you see that?
Holy!
Oh my god!
Grandpa!
Hey, are you alright, honey?
You seem terrified of something explain the recent encounter
yeah i'm telling her someone has it out for you sorry what
oh i don't think grandma is gonna come back oh
i forgot this is a horror game for real though it's been so
chill oh that one was really
hey again kid hello wow so many new flavors and toppings i'm
in the for something spicy.
One spicy ramen, please.
And a tea for me, please.
Just in case it's too spicy.
Yuck.
Green onion.
Mushrooms and nori.
Mushroom.
Nori.
Ugh.
I'm scared to turn around now.
Smells delicious.
Here's a tip for your hard work.
Wow, nice tip.
Thank you.
Alright, ghost.
You can be jealous of my skills, but...
I don't think it warrants me being haunted like this.
One moment, sir.
Beer tower impressed him.
Big books tonight.
Hey there, could I give one chicken ramen and one beer?
It better not be from that side.
Wait, did he just...
One chicken ramen.
What is this, spicy broth?
Which do I listen to?
Wait, the computer or to him?
Wait, which do I listen to?
I'll follow the order list and see what happens.
Boiled eggs in Nori.
Oh, here.
There you go.
By the way, do you smell that?
What smell?
Smells like a rotting animal.
All I smell is my robin.
It's probably just a dead rat.
Oh, I forgot to take out the trash!
Anyway, thanks.
Your...
You apostrophe R-E.
Welcome.
Oh,
yeah, it's my welcome.
Did you see that?
Such a cold, windy day today.
Give me one hot spicy ramen, please.
And two beers.
Spicy ramen, mushrooms, boiled eggs, and corn.
Mushrooms.
Boiled egg.
And corn.
Excellent decision, sir.
Thanks.
You're so welcome.
Congrats on being invited back to Kivoto's Minto.
Thank you.
What should I have for dinner, you guys?
I kind of want ramen.
I think I... Oh, close the shop.
Something spooky is definitely gonna happen.
I fear.
Oh, I have to close the blinds before I start mopping.
Like that dang ghost is gonna be...
hovering around or is gonna ring the bell.
Is that it?
Is that all of it?
Mop the floor.
Where else do I need to mop?
Oh, here.
The stream is making me hungry.
What's your favorite ramen?
I like creamed corn ramen.
With mushrooms.
I like, oh, I like a show you.
That is soy sauce ramen.
Yeah, I like a soy sauce ramen.
And, uh.
Or a miso ramen.
Usually they do, like, the miso with, um, with the corn.
And stuff.
Oh gosh, it's dark again.
good.
This is no good.
I cannot work under these conditions, Mr. Sato.
Mr. Sato.
I cannot work under these conditions.
Wait, I was able to open the blinds.
I'm gonna get jump scared for real.
I'm in the corner.
Let me get one pork ramen and one beer.
My lights are not even on, right?
Wait, are they?
I can't tell.
wait are the lights on did it get darker it's
so dark I think they are on I think I just couldn't tell
maybe it's one of those things where my eyes need to adjust
to the light the glaucoma I'm so huh I could have sworn we
walked in and the lights were off.
Chashu, Naruto Maki, Korn.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, wait, I did add noodles.
Okay, I'm good.
How did you even forget my order?
Wait, what?
Chashu, Naruto Maki, Korn.
Oh, I did forget the...
I did forget the...
Oops.
I forgot the noodles.
Oh.
The corn looked like a noodle.
Chashu.
Naruto maki.
Corn.
Bye-bye.
Took you a hell of a long time.
I spit in that suit, by the way.
I could probably catch a criminal faster.
What a waste of Mr. Sato money.
Mr. Sato's money you are.
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
He's so mean!
Hell get the knife.
This place is haunted, by the way.
It also has terribly dimming lights.
Hey, just one green tea.
Oh.
By the way.
The company I'm working for is looking for janitors.
I think you could fit the role.
No, please get me out of here.
Besides, you barely have customers coming in here.
to chuckle.
Oh, yuck.
You'll be crawling to me for a new job soon.
Watch.
Guys, I feel like this game is
unplayable?
What is that?
Hello?
Is that why it's so dark?
Kitty?
I can't tell.
Hello.
Hey, girl.
I can't see anything.
It's terrible.
Can I get one pork ramen and one green tea, please?
Was that there the whole time?
It couldn't have been.
I would have noticed sooner, right?
Is that a hand?
Mushroom, chashu, boiled eggs.
out?
We're making people?
Wait, what did I miss?
Mushroom, chasu, boiled eggs?
Did I only do one mushroom or something?
Wait, what did I miss?
Mushroom?
Boiled egg?
I think I only did one mushroom.
Ugh, not enough mushroom.
Thanks girl.
Here's a tip, you need it more than me.
I cannot see it.
Oh my god.
Hello?
I can't.
I need new light bulbs.
Oh my god.
Damn, you look like she.
Be useful and give me one spicy ramen and two beers.
Why would you say that?
about me.
Why?
Is something gonna come out of here?
Do I hear my heartbeat?
Chashu, Naruto maki, boiled egg.
Chashu,
It's getting spooky, guys.
Can you even cook?
They smell like they were cooked last year.
Whoever hired you is really stupid.
Everybody speaks so mean to me today!
Oh, this is the worst day of work ever!
There's hands in the...
Ah!
Hello, hey there.
Just one chicken ramen, please.
Ah!
It's air!
Oh my god, his other hand is in the...
Oh,
you're looking at me.
It's kind of cute.
Like, it's all relaxing in the soup.
He's got one hand in the pork.
One hand in the chicken.
Soup demon.
What do you want, Chasunori green onion?
Oh, I think I need to make more.
I'm afraid I'm going to get...
What's it called, though?
I'm going to get jumpsuit.
What was it?
Chasu, Nori, Green Onion?
Yeah.
Nori.
I'm doing my best.
What can I say?
Oh, I forgot the noodles.
One second.
I wish I could open the dang lid.
Chasu.
Nori.
I'll do it my best to green onion.
Okay.
There you go, lady.
Spicy ramen onsen.
Yeah.
She's sobbing.
Are you alright?
My longtime boyfriend cheated on me.
Sorry to hear that.
It's fine.
At least I'm not single like you're sorry ass.
First yellow reviewer ever.
There was a literal...
What?
Handed by Robin.
Did you hear that?
Stop haunting me because you're hearing that I'm having the
worst day ever, please.
Oh, it's time to close the shop.
How am I supposed to tell where there's dirt when I can't
see anything?
I can still see the eyes outside.
That's kind of freaky.
Cry.
I can't see anything.
There's dirt here.
I would just go home.
Just go home.
Let's get up.
I knew.
I knew something was gonna happen.
You dang ghost.
Stop haunting me.
I'm having the worst day.
My god.
I better not see you in the soup tomorrow.
Everybody was so mean to me.
Day six.
Wait, are we outside?
Oh, enter the shop.
Okay.
Ugh.
What a day.
Okay.
What was that?
Hello?
What's going on down here?
The ritual!
Oh my gosh, I almost forgot about it.
What's happening?
What is this?
Mr. Sato!
I'm checking his pulse.
He's gone!
Who could have done this?
I need to call the police.
Oh my god, Mr. Sato!
Use the telephone.
Someone's gonna get me for real.
He was hiding in the lockers.
Hello?
Look who we have here.
You are just as stupid as my brother.
Oh my god.
You know, if he had just given me the shop and None of this
would have happened.
But his stupid old brain decided to hire some random girl
instead of me.
He always treated me like some kind of failure.
Oh, don't do this.
Oh, don't do that.
Always.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Judging.
Well, he can't do that anymore.
Now he lives inside of my freezer 24-7 until I feel like
throwing him.
out but you you are a strong one stronger than anyone that's
been through my curse oh you did the curse but everyone has
their limits and you just met yours young lady time to meet
god meka oh my gosh hashtag freezer life he summoned i
wonder did he what samuel Thank you for playing.
The final course.
Complete the game.
Oh, no.
We died.
I guess there's no good ending because I feel like there
wasn't anything else that I could have done there.
It's just bad ending only.
Oh, dang.
We got, yeah, we got...
Wait, but if I get to be a soup demon, don't tell.
Don't tell.
Nerissa about that don't tell Nerissa she's in the game well
guys that was the ramen shop we did that we did a two well
hidden and what's it called summer games fest today I was
fine I hope you guys enjoyed I had a lot of fun hanging out
with you guys but I'm gonna head off now I'm so hungry for
ramen or something i'm hungry but thank you everybody thank
you thank you so much for stream thank you thank you thank
you sorry we couldn't do that demo sorry it lagged so much
thank you very much for the stream i'm going to order a
pizza now yes i'm gonna possess you i want to buy apparently
thank apparently thank you yes i will i will i will possess
you i will try princess thank you yeah I'd like one ramen
please would you like a pork would you like a chicken or
would you like spicy would you like spicy
traveler you can't handle my spicy ramen oh I forgot to say
oh Phoebe is doing wait let me see it make sure she's still
streaming I said I told her I would raid her today um but
she said that she oh yes phoebe is doing an endurance
karaoke trying to get to oh she just made it everybody go
congratulate phoebe for making it to 50 000 subscribers on
youtube so uh we're gonna raid her make sure you subscribe
so we can get her even higher and higher and higher we don't
want to just stop at 50 000 no um thanks for sgf and the
horror game is gonna do my best concert tickets next week oh
do my best getting concert tickets next week yeah i hope i
see you there ramen seller i'm going to the battle and
require your spiciest ramen you cannot handle my spiciest
ramen and also go tell phoebe congratulations wait what
happened to chara where'd you guys go oh oops there you guys
are everybody oh chara thank you so much for the Salary man
told me to avoid the spicy.
He had a very ashamed look on his face when he said so.
Enjoy your ramen.
Ow!
Thank you!
Thank you so much everybody!
Otomito, go congratulate Phoebe and Golo, subscribe and get
her to higher, higher numbers.
Yeah!
Otomito everybody, thank you so much!
Bye bye!